hi everyone
welcome to yet another video tutorial on
the top 10 reasons to learn python in
2022
python's popularity has grown
exponentially over the past few years
and has been widely used in different
jobs
so this video will focus on the
different reasons why it is important to
learn python in 2022 let's begin
the first reason we have is python is
versatile
python is a totally versatile language
as it has been used widely in artificial
intelligence data science machine
learning web development embedded
systems graphic design applications data
mining gaming and others
python is used as an easier and more
effectively written alternative to
languages that perform similar
functionalities like r and java
now talking about the
second reason why you should learn
python in 2022 we have python is the
fastest growing programming language
python programming has
become one of the fastest growing
programming languages in the world and
is the primary language for many
applications
its popularity has grown both in india
as well as in the us
in january 2021 python was in the third
position in the tob index in january
2022 which is this year
python has become number one in the top
index of popular programming languages
the ratings are based on the number of
skilled engineers worldwide courses and
third-party vendors
popular search engines such as google
bing yahoo wikipedia amazon youtube and
baidu are used to calculate the ratings
coming to our
third reason that is python is
beginner friendly
the main reason why python is an
excellent choice for beginners is its
simplicity
python supports english syntax and is
designed to be concise and easy to read
all of which
make it more accessible to first-time
coders
it is an interpreted programming
language this means that you can run
each line of code once you have finished
writing it allowing you to immediately
check it and make adjustments if needed
the fourth reason we have is python
libraries and frameworks
python provides numerous libraries and
frameworks that cater to every need of
the user and its clients
it has numpy and pandas for numerical
computation and data manipulation scipy
for scientific computation matplotlib
and c bond for data visualization
scikit-learn for machine learning stats
model for statistical analysis and much
more
python also supports frameworks such as
flask and xango for web
applications you can also do cross
platform and cross browser testing with
frameworks like pi test and robot
now moving ahead
the fifth reason we have is python for
data visualization
python is a great programming language
for data analysis and data visualization
so it supports libraries such as
matplotlab c-bond bokeh and plotly for
creating interesting visualizations
you can make sense of complex data sets
and visualize your findings through
various representation options like bar
graph pie charts graphical plots
geographical maps and much more
now moving ahead
the sixth reason we have is
extensive online documentation
python has been adapted to the latest
advancements with developers
continuously releasing new and improved
versions
python language is very organized and
its libraries have co-existing
documentation letting you jump start
straight into programming
you will also find example codes where
you can see the functions implemented so
reading the documentation is a good way
to improve your knowledge about python
moving on to the 7th reason why you
should learn python in 2022 we have
python is great for scripting
python is also used to write scripts to
do automated tasks such as backups and
cleanup in servers
in python you don't have to compile the
code in order to interpret it you can
directly write code in the script and
execute it the machine reads interprets
and runs the required tests and also
performs error checking
now coming to the eighth reason we have
python for cybersecurity
python has been dominating the cyber
security industry and has been around
for a long time now
it can help to automate tasks across the
cyber attack life cycle for both cyber
attackers and defenders
you can develop custom python scripts to
automate cyber security tasks with
libraries such as nmap yara scapy and
twisted
python is used heavily in malware
analysis host discovery
sending and decoding of packets
accessing servers and network scanning
now moving on to our ninth reason we
have
python community support
you always need a community to learn new
technology and friends are your best
asset when it comes to learning a
programming language
the python programming language has a
global community with millions of
software developers who interact online
and offline in thousands of virtual and
physical locations
in case of any coding related issues
you can always seek help from the python
community
as shown on the screen python has a
robust and supportive online community
with over 1.5 million github repository
communities such as stack overflow also
brings several python experts together
to help newbies
now moving on to the
10th reason in our list we have python
jobs in high demand
as python is getting more popular along
with an increase in an active community
and its functions the demand for python
professionals is also increasing
python jobs are increasingly growing in
every business sector and provide high
salaries
python developer is one of the highest
paid jobs in the united states
the average salary of a python developer
in the us is over 96 000
today we're going to cover python one of
today's highly utilized programming
languages for its many diverse uses i'll
be working in pycharm pycharm is put out
by jetbrains that's www.jetbrains.com
pycharm slash where you can download it
the benefits of using pycharm is it
creates a virtual environment so you can
change what version of python you're
using you can make all kinds of
alterations in there for this tutorial
any python ide will work but we'll be in
the pycharm setup it is a really good
setup to use on there and again you can
download it here from the jetbrains
website so in the pycharm environment
and if you're not using this you'll need
to follow whatever ide setup you have
for doing a new project we've created a
new project and we're going to create a
new scratch file this scratch file we
can call whatever it is we want it's
going to be a python file since we're
working in python we'll call it scratch
3 python we can also rename this you can
see i have a number of other scratch
files delete them remove them whatever
you need to do so we're going to be
working on our python in this ide and
again whatever ide you use will work
just fine for this python tutorial and
we're going to start with variables in
python the most fundamental building
block you need variables are entities of
program that hold a value x equals 100
the boxes holding a variable would be
the name given to the box and if you
studied basic algebra x equals 3 x
equals 100 it goes a little bit beyond
just equaling numbers because we can
also do words but we're going to look at
just variables and let's go ahead and
pull that up in our user interface and
see what that programming looks like in
the script language so in python we can
do something like print this is a simple
print statement so whatever we put in
here is printed back out so we're going
to put in here meet jane and let's also
have it print jane works as a software
engineer and then let's also do one more
print line just you can see we're
looking at print and then we have elise
is jane's manager and in here you can
run it a number of ways we'll go
underneath
run and here's our alt shift f10 also
does this and it asks me what do i want
to run i want to run the scratch 3
because i have multiple scratch files in
there and we'll click on there and it'll
run it if you're on like a different id
you might pop up with the black box it
prints it out and you can see here it
says meet jane jane works as a software
engineer elise is jane's manager and
always take that space out so it just
looks nicer so we have that and it's
kind of nice if you just want to print
something out and there certainly is a
lot of times when you want to print the
title of something you might have your
html code on the server and you print it
out and that's what people actually see
if they go to the python and it accesses
that python code it'll print out the
html and they'll just be text printing
it out now this is all great let's go
ahead and put a comment in here just so
we can track what's going on a comment
uses the hashtag uh so this just tells
it this isn't code this is just a
comment for our notes while we're
programming and this over a little bit
so you have a better space on here
instead of typing jane every time we can
also store it as a variable so let's go
ahead and store that and we'll call it
name equals jane so now we have the
variable name and now we can do
something like this we can go print
there's our brackets we want meet and
i'm just going to do a simple comma
everything that's separated between
commas will print out in a row so we
have meat and then we'll just do the
name and if i run this you'll see meet
jane jane works as a software engineer
elise is jane's manager and then just
says meet jane because we replaced the
name with jane and we'll take this off
the top i'm just going to delete that
out of there so we can move on to this
next setup with the variables and we can
also go print this is kind of a cool
system because i can now do string we
can hold a space for a string works as a
software engineer and then if you're
going to put a placeholder in here it
has to know what the placeholder stands
for and this is one of the formatting
options when you print something out so
do something simple like this we have a
placeholder for a string works as a
software engineer except the placeholder
is supposed to be inside the brackets
and when we hit run you'll see meet jane
and then he also prints jane works as a
software engineer and see that right
down here in the output the terminal
output from the run so instead of having
to type jane over and over again we can
now put a placeholder in there and do
the same thing with the last setup print
elise is and there's our placeholder the
percentage sign and the s and then we
have name afterward let's go ahead and
run that and you can see here that we've
now printed out the the first one meet
jane and notice that this puts more a
little bit more it has one space in here
but you don't really control the spacing
on here so when we do a formatting and
we insert it as part of the format you
can see right here we put the name it
now has a nice format like i couldn't do
this with a comma but i can certainly do
this down here with the apostrophe s for
elise's jane's manager and then we can
also instead of having jane up here
maybe jane got fired and may got hired
well let's just say there's a second
employee named may so now we have the
name may in here and i can run this and
you'll see it now prints meet may may
works as a software engineer elise's
maze manager so we've just swapped may
in for jane and then one other important
feature of python variables is we could
have name two also equal to
may keep the same name on there and
let's go ahead and print we'll do id
of name and then i also want to print
the id of name two and what the id does
is the id goes in there and says hey
where is this name coming from let's go
ahead and run that and you'll see it
actually gives us a memory address and
so one of the things you find out about
python is to help save memory let me
just swap this out here in python
variables with the same value hold the
same memory space so we have name equals
to may name two equals may we print the
idea of name and name two and you'll see
that they occupy the same memory space
now if we happen to swap one of these
out we'll do jane again and we run it
they now have two different memory
spaces so even though i make changes in
here this is one of the ways that python
is really good about saving memory in
the computer and the last thing we want
to note here which leads us into the
next piece of programming is that this
is a string up here name equals jane so
we're talking about different data we
really have to also talk about different
data types and very specifically we're
going to look at numerical data so we
talk about numeric data talking numbers
the various types of numeric data are
integer float and complex there are an
advanced programming additional
numerical data types which have to do
how it stores the data but these three
are the ones that you need to know about
to get started in your scripting
language and the most commonly used and
so an integer is just simply that it's a
number equals five and then if i print
and you can always find out what type of
variable you have if you do a type on it
so we're going to print type number and
so if i run this it comes out and it
says class integer down here so this is
an integer number and you can also do
negative on these so if i run minus 5
it's still a class integer whether it's
plus or minus and the most the second
most commonly used number is your float
and it's just like it sounds we have
let's do a number equals
5.6 and if you notice i used the same
variable name num on there so i can
actually take this and i can just copy
this and at some point we'll talk about
ways of not having to recopy your code
so you can create definitions but let's
go and take a look at this we have our
float our number now equals 5.6 and if
we print the number type we'll see that
it is first an integer and then a float
value and let's do this just to number
just remember we're looking at number
and then finally complex so if we have a
complex number we'll go ahead i'm going
to keep number in there usually you
don't leave it as number because then it
confuses the code later on but just for
this particular piece of code we're
going to keep it number and i'm going to
do 5 plus 6j and let's go ahead and
print that out so we can see what these
look like and here's our number comma
type number and let's run this and let's
see we got here we have a 5 which is an
integer 5.6 which is a float so it has a
decimal place there that's what the
float stands for so your 5.6 5.7 5.8 and
then we have 5 plus 6j is a complex
number and if you remember from math
complex number is based off of i squared
equals minus 1 or the square root of
minus 1 is that imaginary number now
i'll be honest with you i don't use
imaginary numbers much unless something
comes up where i take a square root of a
minus one and then i end up with a
return of a complex number so it's
important to know it's there and know
what it is when it comes up and with
anything you do have to be pay attention
when you do conversions so we can
convert these things back and forth and
let's go ahead and put a little note
here versions and let's start by
oh let's just do here's our print and
we'll go ahead and do our number comma
type back to what we were doing before
so we know what the type it is and type
number so that's just from before on
there and let's say we want to convert
it from a regular number to a float and
we can simply do something that looks
like this and let's go ahead and pull
ways there's our number but i want to
convert it so i'm going to convert it to
float and then if we do that over here
too and i go float that in brackets so
we're going to print this out and if i
run this we now have 5 as a class
integer 5.0
is a float so i've converted it to a
float here and we can also convert this
to a complex just like we did here with
float i can simply put in complex and
we'll do that over here also complex
number and if i run this we now have
five plus oj so this is a complex number
there's no actual negative imaginary
numbers is part of it so you're going to
get just a zero in the j part um so this
is one way to convert it and you convert
it this way we can also convert it back
so you can convert to any between any of
these and let's take our number and
let's make it worth
5.6 so if you remember correctly this is
now a float and if we wanted to take
that float value print integer of our
number and of course type integer of our
number and if we run this we started off
here with 5.6 so by default it
automatically makes it a float value and
here we have it we converted a float to
a float so it's not going to really do
anything and then we convert it to an
integer and look what happens as an
integer as an integer it just truncates
the six right off so you gotta be very
careful when you're going the wrong
direction on this so if you're going
from float to integer you're gonna lose
a decimal value if you're going from
integer to float which is very common
thing to do especially with data science
you don't lose anything you just gain
the decimal place so if i when we did it
earlier we had five became 5.0 and then
you can see where it becomes a complex
number and we can do that just about any
direction you want with the conversion
python is really nice that it lets you
do that but you do have to be careful
that you don't lose information that you
need so we've looked at variables we've
looked at numerical variables and how
they differ the next question is what
happens if you have a lot of data you
really can't just number one number two
number three that's really not going to
work in programming so three of our
basic lists is lists in python a list is
a collection of data and it can hold
values of multiple data types so you can
see here we've set a value a variable x
and we'll set it equal to 189 a a 0 b
and it can store that in there there's
also the tuple so we have list tuple and
set the tuple almost has the same format
as the
list but instead we put the curved
brackets around it and what this means
is a tuple is an immutable collection of
heterogeneous data big mouthful there
what it means is once i set the tuple i
can't go in there and change one piece
of it as far as the tuple is concerned
that's one variable where a list is a
list of sub variables 189a 0b a tuple
you can't change anything in here now
you can access it the same way you do a
list but you can't make any changes on
this tuple other than completely
overwriting it and then finally there's
a set and we put brackets around it now
there's some other more complex data
sets that go with this to go above our
data type collections of data but these
are the three basics and the set is an
unordered collection of unique
heterogeneous data so it's unique so if
you put in 1 5 3 hey 6 python and i try
to add 6 in here you'll only store one
value of 6 since these are all unique in
here so let's jump into our ide and
let's create a list remember it uses
square brackets that's how we denote
that this is going to be a list let's
just throw some numbers in there four
five seven five so now i have a list and
we can do a simple thing like print the
list and if we run this we'll see it
come out down here as one four five two
seven five and one of the cool things
about lists is that these are indexes
and this is kind of important to
understand what the index means so we'll
go ahead and print list and it always
starts with zero so if i run this and i
print zero it's going to print the one
because that's in the zero place and if
we print here's our list we print a one
on there and we run that we have four
that's in the one place so zero one two
three four five so there's zero through
five and this is interesting because if
we print let me go back up here to the
top i'm just going to print lin which
stands for length of list this is going
to return the length of the list and i'm
going to run this and you'll see it says
there's six things in there but it
starts at zero so we reference them as
zero through five now if you're new to
this that can be confusing especially
when you're jumping back and forth in
your code so always remember this is
point zero through five it's not one
through six is zero through five but
there are six entities in the list
that's the length of the list and we
showed you here where you can access
your zero index your one index you can
also access it from the right hand side
by simply adding a negative number in
there so if i add a negative one and i
run this helps if i actually put the
list in front of it there we go run
you'll see that it points to the last
one in the list so negative one is the
five this again a little confusing you
can't do a negative zero so negative one
going backwards it starts at one and if
i change the negative one say to two
you'll see it'll go to the seven prints
the 7 out there so we can do some very
basic indexing and look at any one of
these entities in the list and then get
the length of the list so we know how
long our list is now really common is
not just to want one entity instead of
wanting just one entity in here let me
just get rid of some of the notes here
so that we can see what this looks like
i might want to access the first four
values so i can do print list 0 4. and
your first thought might be that we
count this 0 1 2 3 4 which would be five
entities but we don't count the four so
this is zero to three so whenever you
see this axis from left to right
positive side it's going to give us the
first four element but it starts with
zero zero one two three which is our one
four five two and since we're starting
from the beginning you can always just
leave the zero out and we can do
something like this this gives us the
same answer whether you put the zero in
or leave the zero out it automatically
assumes you're starting from the
beginning of the list
likewise we can start from position two
and go forward and if you notice here we
get five two seven five position two if
you look at this we have zero one two
two points to the five position so if
you're going from left to right you just
say hey i want position 2 and you get
everything to the end and we could also
put a second number in here like 4.
that's just 2 3 you get 2 values
remember it doesn't include the 4 on
here it does include the 2. just like
you can do indexes with negative numbers
i can now do minus four so this means
that i'm starting with zero i can leave
it out so the python way is to leave it
out you don't need all that extra script
and it goes up to a negative four well
where is negative four here's one two
three four so this should go up to this
location but not included and sure
enough we get one four so it goes up two
negative four remember when you're
reading it this way from left to right
you don't include the minus four include
the first one but not the second one and
you can also put the negative over on
the other side and go minus four and if
we run this one now we get five two
seven five so we have one two three four
and remember it's on the left hand side
so we include it so we have five two
seven five coming out in the bottom and
the last really fun trick you can do let
me just take the minus four out is i'm
gonna add a second colon here and a two
and i'm gonna run this and it should
print out every other one so goes one it
skips one so it counts at one two one
two and we get the one five and seven
coming out and you can see that down
here and you can add in any of your
other numbers in here so we can start at
one instead of at zero and now you get
four two five so again we're skipping
every other one but now we're starting
with the digit in the index number one
place last thing to note is that these
are all integers if i put a 1.0 in and i
run it it's going to give me an error it
says i can't slice a float value even
though it knows what one is it needs to
be an integer and that's important to
know if you're slicing your data into
thirds i don't know how many times i
forget to do that change it convert it
back to an integer and it'll say i can't
slice 3.6666 or whatever it is so
remember to convert that into integers
so another thing to remember about lists
they can be mixed so i can come in here
and instead of it being all in this case
we had all integers i could easily put
python in here and instead of seven
we'll do seven point four comma five and
if i print this out let me just take
that out of here and by the way this
this functionality of the index works
identical no matter what's in your list
but we come in here and you'll see i
have one for python 2 7.45 and lists are
mutable so just like i did just like i
referenced the index i can say list of
let's do one which is going to be the
fourth place equals uh let's do hello
and if i print my list now you'll see
down below where it comes out goes from
one for python to 7.45 to one hello
python to 7.45
and because these are mutable with the
lists we can also do something like list
dot append and we can append simply
learn and now if i print my list out and
i run this you'll see that i've added
simply learn to the end of the list and
if i do a length of the list it's now
gone from six to seven oh let's just do
that real quick print length of list so
now it's seven so we've added one more
unit to the list they're very mutable
very flexible use of
setting up lists and then we can also
take this list let's do a new one we'll
call it nested we can create nested
lists uh what that means is that here's
my brackets to define that it's a list
and i can fill this with whatever
objects i can think of these can be
anything but we'll stick to numbers i'll
do one two and then i'm gonna also
create a nested list and we'll create
two comma three comma four so now i have
a list within a list so now we have a
nested list and if we print this let's
just print our nested list out you'll
see down below it prints it out just
like i typed it one two comma two three
fours and nested inside the nested list
and then another option to append is we
can also do nested extent and we could
go in here and let's let's create my
nested loop so i'm adding a nested loop
to a nested loop this is kind of
interesting because you'll see here i
have a sub list attached to the list and
i'm going to take the nested extent i'm
going to extend this on here and if i
run this if i
take this and run this let me make sure
i print the nested again you can see how
it's been transformed and i got one two
two three four and it's added the seven
eight nine on there now i was just
adding one nested list on here i'd
probably just append brackets around
seven eight nine but if you were adding
multiple nested lists on here you might
do something you want to use the extend
on here so we have one two uh sublist
234 sub list 789 and sub list five six
seven they've added two different new uh
nested lists onto this so we've looked
at lists we've covered indexing of lists
we've covered appending or extending and
sub-lists let's go ahead and talk about
tuples and tuples are really important i
am amazed when i first heard about them
i was like why why have a list and why
have a tuple so the tuple is your curved
brackets around in this case we're going
to do one two three and the most
important thing to know about the tuple
is i can't change it i can't go in there
and change the one to a zero now i can
change tuple and have it equal something
else but i can't change the pieces of
the tuple and that's what's so important
about the tuple on this and you'll see
when i print it it also prints it with
the curved brackets so that lets me know
that this is immutable i cannot change
the tuple now we can access the tuple
just like you did the list i can print
tuple position one and if i run that
it's going to print two because remember
we start with zero one i can do just the
same way we did the indexing i can do up
to one which should print just the one
because zero and it doesn't include the
one there's our tuple comes out with one
comma so a little different output
you'll see this kind of notation when
you're accessing slices of a tuple and
you know all the different functionality
for indexing is the same we can even do
it in reverse we didn't show you that on
the list but this works just as well on
the list instead of the 2 for skipping
we can do a minus 1 and that just goes
in reverse so now i have a tuple of 3 2
1. so i talk about it not being able to
be changed if we take and just get rid
of the print for a second and let's
print let's do this
tuple of 1 is now going to equal 7. if i
run this it's going to throw an error
because we cannot change the pieces of
the tuple i can reassign something else
to tpl my variable but i can't change it
it's immutable and one of the very
common uses of a tuple is to use it as a
key for something else now we're not
going to cover keys and codes in this
tutorial but imagine if you have an
address to a house and the house is 123
main street and someone can just change
that address then your house just kind
of jumps all over the place so you want
that address to be unchangeable
immutable and this is like a key code so
it's probably a key to some data so it's
a reference usually at some point or
some kind of data that can doesn't needs
to be set and unchanged when you set it
for a tuple and we can do there's some
other cool things we can do with a tuple
now let's just take this one we can do
something you can there's what they call
packing and unpacking tuples so just
like we assigned the tuple one two three
i can also do tuple equals we'll do five
six eight just because and if i print
tuple and we run that it's still going
to create a tuple out of it and so we're
saying hey this tuple is equal to these
three values whatever they are and now
this variable is equal to these three
values and automatically converts it
into a tuple if you do it that way and
we can unpack our tubal i can do a comma
b comma c equals tuple and if we print a
comma b comma c run that you'll see we
get our 5 6 8 right back so we can
unpack it and pack it you see this a lot
when you're doing definitions in
programming where you're packing and
unpacking the data you'll get to the
point when you're doing scripting you
don't really even notice or think about
it until you're like oh yeah that is a
tuple remind you on that one but it does
come up a lot and then another strange
thing i can do is i can do a star list
now in this list is a variable and a is
also our letter a just from right above
and i'm going to set that equal to a
tuple and let's print that out let's
print a comma list and if i run this
you'll see that i get 5 which is our a
and then it creates a list out of the
remainder so once i've pulled a out of
the first part i now have list in there
and i could have done a comma b comma c
equals tuple so this is straight from up
above where we have a b c equals tuple a
comma star list just splits them up into
two parts the first part it refers to is
just the value and the second part it
puts into a list square brackets so you
can see how that's set up in there and
how you can pull that information and
manipulate it and then we'll finally
we'll look at set and you can create a
set
s equals and usually you denote it with
the squiggly brackets and one two three
three four five and if you look at this
if you remember the set should not
repeat any values so if i print set and
i run this i now get one three four five
and i've got rid of all my duplicate
threes so i can only have unique values
in a set and if we're looking at this
this is also a subgroup of a tuple so
that means that if i do s of 1 and i try
to change one of the members in there
equals one so i'm trying to change
position one which is a three to a one
and i run that it's going to give me an
error i can't change it i can't append
to it so it's just like a tuple i can't
change these values in the set what i
can do is i can take a list
and uh let's just let's just change this
we'll go list equals we'll change these
to square brackets so now i have my
standard list and we'll do a list down
here print our list and then i'm going
to print and we'll use the keyword set
and we're going to change this from a
list to a set and then i'll go ahead and
print that out and if i run this you'll
see that my list has all the values but
the second i convert it to a set which
is a special kind of tuple that doesn't
let you repeat values you'll see that it
gets rid of all my duplicates so now i
have one three four five in there in my
set so now we've looked at a lot of
different ways to store our data in
different variables we have our list
variable we had our basic variables we
had our tuple we showed you how to do a
set let's start doing something with
this information we'll start with
arithmetic operators the most basic ones
plus minus divide let's just take a look
and see what that looks like and we'll
need some variables to play with so we
can look through the basics and if you
remember we did a comma b equals or b
equals a comma b and all that we can
actually do a comma b equals 10 comma 5.
that's nothing more than what we already
did just a little different formatting
what i'm saying is the a equals the 10
the b equals the 5. that's all that is
and i could write that out a equals 10 b
equals 5 just as easily and our basic
arithmetic operators you're going to see
is we have
a plus b we'll do this ctrl copy put a
bracket around it so we have our a plus
b set up on here and if we run this we
should get what we expect a plus b 10
plus 5 equals 15. and we can do that all
kinds of different ways fact if we look
at all the basic operators let me just
do it now let's keep it this way we can
take this and we have instead of a plus
b we'll do a minus b and let me grab
that and put that over here and let me
just go down this and do them all in one
shot there we go paste them right in
there and most of these should be pretty
familiar the first four are your a plus
b a minus b a times b a divided by b and
so we look at that we get a plus b is 15
a minus b is five ten minus five is five
multiply and we get fifty a divided by b
gives us two point zero and now we hit
kind of an unusual one we have a double
slash b two what this is saying is that
if there's a remainder let's just
convert it to an integer remember i was
telling you earlier i sometimes have to
slice my data so into thirds instead of
going length divided by three i could do
length slash slash over 3 and that gives
me an integer and it just tells me hey
where's my first third of data in
where's that at but if you do that you
also want to know what the remainder is
so that's what the amber sign is is a or
percentage sign that's what the
percentage sign is a percentage sign b
equals 0. and then finally you can
square it and whoops i forgot to put
that as a 2. data science you tend to do
a lot of squaring you do like the square
means error so it's very common to see
something to the power of 2. and so
you'll see that a times times 2 gives
you u squared value this is actually b b
squared is 25 5 times 5 is 25. so these
are your basic arithmetic operators this
really with the first four there's no
surprises you just have a surprise here
when you do a double slash because it
returns the integer and just drops the
decimal when you have the percentage
sign it gives you just the return value
so 5.5 comes back as 0.5 and then you
have your the double star is your
squared so b double star 2 is squaring
your value and we can take any of these
functions and assign them so i could do
res as my variable equals a plus b
and then res now becomes equal to a plus
b which should be 15 when i run it and
sure enough there's my 15. so now i can
take a and b and they might come in from
all kinds of different areas and set
another variable that goes out to where
whoever needs it returns it to the other
part of the program is res and again
this is true whether we do a plus b
a times b a divided by b any of those
basic functions is going to give us the
set the variable res to that now we can
also do what they call shorthand for a
lot of this so we'll do counts the most
common one you do a count equals zero
because you want to know it runs a
process adds one to it runs a process
adds run to it so we can do count equals
count
plus one and then if i print count
you'll see right here we get count
equals count plus one i get one zero
plus one is one i can also do we'll just
do it up here count equals but instead
of putting the equals argument but plus
equals one and this means i take count
and i might as well put the count here
and the plus sign and we can run that
and you'll see it now equals two so i
get count equals count plus one count
plus equals one is the same thing so
i've added another one to it and now i
have two and we can actually do this
with anything in any of the main i could
do count times equals so itself times
one and of course one times one is one
so we'll do something a little bit more
exciting like one times three and i get
three and we could do this instead of
with count let's do a divide equals 2
and that's print a if we run that we get
5. so i've taken a which is 10. i've
divided it by 2. a divided by 2 is 10
and again any of these operators that we
just looked at i can now do down here
there's the integer version we can do
the percentage sign run that has a zero
remainder so that's what comes up with
it maybe remember i was doing thirds if
we do thirds we can see i get a
remainder of one if i do divide a
divided by three there's my three point
three three three three very common but
then i can also do the double divide and
i get just my three out of there so a
whatever your arithmetic operator goes
here equals three is the same as a
equals a whatever operator you put there
in the three so we had our basic
arithmetic operators uh we want to look
at relationship or relational operators
and whenever you think of relationship
think true false is this true or is it
false and again we can do our print
we'll go a comma b just so we have it
down here take this out it take clearing
my palette a little bit there and so we
have our 10 5 and then we can do a print
a is greater than b and if you're
listening closely i said think true
false is a greater than b is 10 greater
than 5 and if we run that we get true
and if you remember we did with
arithmetic and you wonder where i'm
going with this you'll see that we have
all of our basic operators we have a is
greater than b a is less than b a is
greater than or equal to b a is greater
than or is less than or equal to b a
equals b notice this double equal sign a
little different there and then we have
an asterisk on the bottom so let's go
ahead and run this and you can see down
here is a greater than b true is a less
than b that's false is a greater than or
equal to b it's still going to be true
is a less than or equal to b still going
to be false and then a double equal sign
well because the equal sign is used in
python to set variables and to set
values whenever you do a logic where you
want to know if it's equal you have to
use the double equal sign that's very
important and of course is a equal to b
the answer is false remember double
equal sign and then if you're going to
have an equals you should have a not
equals so here's our not which is the
exclamation point and you can see that a
is not equal to b equals true so as we
go through here we have our logical uh
our basic relational operators which are
logic gates on here and we can take this
up a notch to do this let me just go
ahead and create a little bit of
different data here and in this case i'm
going to create an a1 b1 c1 equal to 10
20 30 and of course we print those out
as you guessed it it should be just
those values individually let me take
this clear my palette a little bit and
run that and you can see we get 10 20 30
down here and if we pop up this is where
it kind of gets interesting is we're
going to print we're going to use the
same operators we were just using but
we're going to do
c1 greater than a1 we're going to add an
extra logic in here and c1 is greater
than b1 so i'm asking here's c1 equals
30 is it greater than 10 and and is a
greater than 20. and if i run that we
get true because that you know it is c1
is greater than a1 c1 is greater than b1
now what happens if we had a1 is greater
than b1 and c1 is greater than b1 well
if we run this we're going to end up
with false because a1 is not greater
than b1 but we can instead of n we can
do or so if i run this we'll now get
true because c1 is still greater than b1
so there's our or value and you can
stack these i could do a1 greater than
b1 or c1 b1 you could end up with a very
lengthy logic statement at some point
you got to avoid that you have to find
another means to do that but those are
two basic ones is and and or and then
finally not so i can take any of these
logic gates and i can change them from
a1 is greater than b1 to not a1 is not
greater than b1 so is a1 greater than b1
no this would return false but then we
just reverse it with the not and it
comes out as true so let's go ahead and
clear this and we're going to look at a
very complicated i don't know if it's
really complicated we're going to touch
upon what easily becomes a complicated
subject which is bitwise operators in
python so you can imagine let's just go
back to what is it we had our a b 10 and
five so let's go back there and pull
that back in here so we're gonna have
our two variables a b ten and five and
we're gonna look at bitwise operators to
understand the bitwise operator let's go
ahead and print binary of a go ahead and
do the binary of b and we're not going
to dig too deep into this i just want
you to be aware of it for more advanced
programming and you'll see it comes out
here here's the bit value which is your
one zero one zero and this would be all
zeros up until there and that's what the
zero b means it's binary and everything
else on this side is zero and this is
the same thing five is represented by
101 10 is represented by 10 10 in binary
when you switch it over so we look at
this binary switches we're going to do
that we can go let's do
print
a and b so if we run this we end up with
0 and that's kind of interesting because
how the heck do they get 0 out of that
you know this is 10 10 and 101. well if
you line this up this one on the right
hand side lines up with the zero so
guess what that's zero we take this zero
we landed up with this zero and guess
what we get we get zero there's no and
it's not the same value and we have one
and zero so we're doing a if this equals
this if this equals this and if this
equals this we get print a which prints
out was it printout zero because none of
them match and we can do something like
print
a and you use the up down bar and unless
you do a lot of work with this you
almost always have to look it up if
you're dealing with binary number or
with shifts and things like that of
where these decimal places are and so
we're going to do a
or b if we run that we get 15 and if we
print let's just print this in binary so
you can see what that looks like so if
we print a or b in binary let's run that
so remember up here we got zero i forgot
to convert print print let's try that
again let's print this in binary and if
we print this in binary you'll see now
that it's an or so we have one or one
equals one zero one zero or one equals
one one or zero equals one it gets kind
of confusing there but you can see where
if either one has a one in its uh place
or a it then comes out as one and so we
get one one one one and it does turn out
that when you print this out it came out
as fifteen so if you do a binary or
statement on these two numbers you get
15 on there and we can do this we can
continue this down there are exclusive
so we can do print
and we'll do this instead of a or b
we'll do an exclusive which is your
little tilde we can run that and it's
going to return the same thing because
this is exclusively one so if this had
been one one one one and this has been
one zero one zero we would have seen the
one zero one zero come through on the
exclusive where the or returns all ones
and if you have exclusive
you can also have one's complement so
this is like negating your number so we
can do
just do this
binary and
this is the other squiggly of a and we
run that and we'll see that this googly
comes out as 1.011 so it reverses it
it's a little different on this because
we are looking at a ones complement on
there so it changes your logic thinking
on there and unless you do a lot of work
with it can really tie your brain in a
knot it's kind of fun to figure out if
you play with it and then finally we
have a couple more cool things you can
do this this we can do uh print we can
do what they call a shift and i'll go
and put this in binary because it's
really hard to make sense of it if
you're not doing binary and we can do
shift two this shifts it to the left so
you can see right here we've added two
zeros on the right hand side to our a
and we have the same number and shifted
it all to the left and we can also shift
it the other way shift it this way and
we can run that and now we just shift it
off and these two just get bumped off
and we end up with the last two digits
the one zero because we're shifting
everything to to the right oops i'm
sorry we dropped the one zero did it
backwards since we're shifting it to the
right we lose this one zero and we end
up with just this first one zero and
this is when you get into like a huge
array of trues false yes no and you need
to compare them and you can do all kinds
of cool things in here again it's a very
advanced logic when you're doing bitwise
operators but it's important to know
they're there and understand what they
are so when it does come up you know
where to look for them and finally
talking about logic we'll need to go
ahead and look at membership operators
very useful thing to have let's just do
a list equals i will do one two back
there one two three four five uh so we
have our basic list and the question is
let's assign a variable x x equals two
and so let's go print
x in list and what do you think that's
going to print is x in the list is 2 in
there and the answer is yes so we get
true so it's going to print true in
there and you can remember we can also
add the not in there is x not in list we
run that it equals false and when we
start looking later on here or shortly
at our if else list and wireless you'll
see where this comes in handy to get
these true false statements on here and
then we have identity operator clear our
palette identity operator and this is oh
let's do x equals 10 y
equals 10 and let's print x is y and if
we run this we get true because remember
when python points to the memory it
stores the 10 in the same place and so x
is y and if we change this to y equals
12 it will now give us a false because
they're no longer equal so you could
also replace this with x i don't do a
lot of x y is y it does come up so you
need to be aware of it but it's not
usually just do x equals y false but x
is y i changed it to 12 so again false
and then you can also go in here x is
not y so is y or is not y and it's true
it is not y so these are all the basic
functions arithmetic functions that you
find with your python install what we're
going to cover next is what happens if
it's not in there what happens if you
have some more complicated math
equations you need to run well at that
point you got to import math so the
import it's important to know what the
import is uh if we have an external
module to python so it's not part of the
basic python code you import that module
and math is used so much that they have
it bundled with the python install but
by default it doesn't load into your ide
into your user face or into the program
so when you go to use math you have to
run the import on there and let's just
take a look and see what some of the
stuff that math covers now i did a quick
uh bing search and it took me to python
this is always nice because we have the
actual version here which version of
python you're in the documentation
python and then we went to the math
module and in the math module we have
ceiling we have copy the sign fabs
factorial floor ceiling and floor kind
of interesting because it's just really
from an external viewpoint it's rounding
up or rounding down but there's other
things that go on behind the scenes that
you might use this instead and then
there's here's our basic functions and
if you scroll down you can see it just
covers all kinds of different things
like is it finite is it infinite is it a
nand modify f powers so if we're going
to do an exponential we saw how to
square a value but if you wanted to do
something to the third or the fourth you
have to import the math module to do
that and you can see here we have
exponential of one this is like
exponential x minus 1 log x all your log
functions are in here square root
there's one that comes up a lot in data
science if you're going to take the
square means of a value for your error
cosine signs tangents all the different
trigonometric functions all this is in
the math and really we're not going to
cover all the different things you can
do in math because that's its own domain
if you're working with degrees and
radians or hyperbolic functions there's
just a lot in the math module including
mathematical constant e tau infinite
nand pi there's your pi in there so all
this stuff is in your math module and
when we're in here we can do something
simple like print math pi if i run this
it should give me the value of pi which
it does 3.141 so on any of the functions
in here if you import math you could
import something like this you could
import another option let's say i wanted
just the pi value and we could do
something like this we could also do
from
math so it tells it to go to the math
module import pi if we do this we don't
need the math in front of it so we're
just importing the pi and i can run this
and now you can see i have pi here same
thing and we can do all the
functionality that you saw earlier let's
go back to uh import math and instead of
pi let's go ahead and do go and do a
variable so we can put in x equals 9.5
and then from here from our math we can
do if you remember from the very top
they had the ceiling which i said was
the same as rounding it up we could do
print ceiling of x and if i run this it
should give us 10. so ceiling is
actually the nearest integer that's
greater than 9.5 you could also do again
there's a cosine tangent all of these
functionalities are in your math module
let's see what tangent looks like 0.0753
there you go and then there's a couple
that i see regularly in the coding one
is power so i could do x equals 9.5 y
we'll just stick to three and we can do
x to the y
or x cubed and we can see we get 857.375
i use the power when i'm trying to
figure out how long it's going to take
to run certain programs especially when
you're going through a lot of
permutations you might find yourself
going okay i got three permutations and
each permutation has three different
variations well that's three to the
three so if i run it once through i can
guess at the time it's going to run by
doing three to the three and then i can
just program it to guess what my time
output is another one is of course
square root so we can do the square root
of that's another very common one square
root especially in data science when
you're computing the error we can do the
square root of x so we can do the square
root sqrt of x and if i run this i'll
print the square root again you know
data science the square root means error
there's your square root factorials
that's another one of those things that
come up probably not as much but if
we're doing the factorial we'll do y
this time and we run it this is adding
up all the numbers up to three so this
is one plus two plus three and it equals
six again those are just a few of the
different mathematical functions you can
do and you can go over to python and see
the full slew of them on the website so
so far we've looked at uh data type
storing data math functions so some
things that you can do with the data
that comes in let's go ahead and cover
another area we're going to go into
input and we'll look at this is a very
basic way of inputting data and more
specifically uh inline input so this is
not your windows interface or frames
interface or windows xy interface and
there is interfaces for python whether
you're exporting it into an html or some
other format that then feeds the data
back into python there's a lot of
different options there but this
specifically is just inline and what
that means is we need to find a way to
get the data in so we'll do name input
there's our input command and then the
first part is the prompt this is what
it's going to prompt you for it says
enter your name and we'll add a the
scoop i like to call it but backward
slash in this case n this stands for new
line that's what this little these two
symbols next to each other is and the
backward slash is a escape key so if you
actually need to put a variable in with
a backward slash like i want enter
your let's do enter get your name this
will print a backward slash and this
will prompt us for our name and if i hit
enter you'll see enter get your name and
when i click down here type in richard
which is my name and hint enter then it
continues the code on there and then we
can do something with this we can do
print and we'll do hi comma name and
remember with the print this just simply
prints whatever the first one is comma
the second one comma and so on and so i
can now hit this in here when i go down
here it prompts me for my name enter get
your name maybe it's kind of a weird way
of putting it hi richard we'll change
this from get to enter input and we
might continue on down here so we'll go
ahead and do input age i'll do page
equals input enter your age and we'll do
that same backward slash n and this time
instead of printing the age we're going
to enter in a an integer this is kind of
a very important thing to know when
you're doing line inputs if i run this
and we print type of the age let's just
go ahead and go through this enter
richard and it's going to say hi richard
enter your age we won't put down my real
age we'll say i'm a young 25 it's
actually significantly less than my age
and this is interesting because it takes
the input and it's a string that's what
this class string means so whenever you
do an input like this it comes in as a
string and that's important to know
because if you're trying to add age to
something it's not going to come out
very get an error so i could do print
age plus five because age is a string
when i come in here and i just do this
real quick misspelled my work my name
type error must be string not integer so
it's trying to add five which is an
integer to a string which you can't do
so that's very important when you're
coding you start getting those kinds of
errors that's where they're coming from
is you got to make sure your two types
match and one way i mean you can convert
it i don't know if you remember from
conversions i can simply put integer age
we'll do integer age plus one just you
can see how it's different and it will
convert it to age or to a number on here
to an integer we enter in our name we
enter in our pretend age and you'll see
that it now is able to add one to that
age because i've converted it to an
integer you can be a little careful with
this because you might have characters
in there that aren't integer in which
case it'll give you an error at that
point let's do two more things with this
let's go ahead and print with a format
so we have name and age and let's say
we'll do first formatting and we'll put
in an s in there is second formatted
word years old and if you remember from
the formatting we can now take this add
our amber sign at the end or percentage
and then we put the two variables name
and age in here and then i can go ahead
and run this and if we run this we enter
click down here if we run this i can
type in my name type in my pretendage if
you said tuple you've got that right so
you gotta remember i'm sending it as a
tuple it's what the curve brackets due
to it so now we run this it should give
me a nice format on here so it looks
pretty sometimes that's really important
because people are coming in see this
all the time instead of these nice forms
that come up we used to see it where i
do prompts like this for people coming
in and we'll see that we get an error
down here because d looks for a
decimal we have two strings so we could
do something like this integer age so
and now if i run it i shouldn't have any
errors on there i should come in here 25
and there we go richard is 25 years old
and so we did a couple things in here we
now have our formatting we now have
string versus decimals what the d stands
for that's pretty much any number and
make sure we give it a number so we have
a setup on there and you would probably
want to double check their input if this
was for a form fill out or something
like that although this usually i use
this for small programs where i'm
testing something out and i got to put a
different input in each time i don't use
them very often but it does come up it
does come up where you might need to
test something out real quick or have a
line input for a very long script you're
running and they just need a simple line
input and one of the last things we can
do on here is we can take this and let's
say
instead of enter
input name how about a word and we're
going to do on this word if you remember
from before we had our indexes for our
list well a word of any kind is nothing
more than a string of characters and
that string is stored in a list so i can
come in here and take name and i can say
hey i just want the first
four letters of that of your name maybe
that's what it is and we'll print we'll
just keep it name maybe you're creating
a username or reference i've seen this
where they have passwords and things
like that set to the first four letters
i hit enter it's going to return rich
just the first four letters and that's
because this index works just like it
does in a list it's the same index as it
is a list before we move on to the next
section one more thing i want to note
about input a equals integer if you
remember correctly we did a conversion
where if you had the num number in here
three a character this converts it to an
integer gives you an error if you put a
in there we can also do this as a single
line this is very common in python to
try to bring stuff together they call it
the python way just makes it a little
easier to read let's say you can see
right here enter a multiple of we'll do
five in this case this actually converts
it so if i go ahead and put in down here
print a we run this to five we get five
and if i type in the type of a it will
of course see the list of type integer
we'll just go ahead and run this real
quick print five class integer so this
is just a way of combining the
conversion with the input you can put it
all in one line like this make it nice
and compact so what we want to cover
next is the if statements and there's
like the if the else the lf we're also
going to start into the loops we're
going to cover the while statement which
uses the logic gate in the loop and then
we'll look at the four or four statement
which is just a loop without logic and
of course there's a couple of odds and
ends break and continue which go with
the loops so the if statement this is
where we start doing something with the
data we're putting in so you'll see here
i went ahead did uh input enter multiple
of five and maybe we want to know if it
is a multiple of five so if a how can we
do that we can do a
divided by five and get the remainder
off of that is not equal to zero so just
a little simple logic there this returns
true false if remember we covered all
that true false statements so if it's
not equal to zero then it doesn't then
if it's equal to zero it has no
remainder so it's multiple of five if
it's not equal to zero it has a
remainder which means that it is then
not a multiple of five and we can just
simply have a print
and we'll just uh we'll do this we'll go
a comma not a multiple of five and if i
run this and i enter in and let's just
enter in three three not a multiple of
five and if we have another piece of
code down here we'll just print this is
what happens next so we might have some
more script down here and if we run that
we enter in five it just goes right down
to this is what happens next and if we
go back we put in 4 you'll see that 4
comes up and says 4 is not a multiple of
5 this is what happens next and so the
if statement only runs if this is true
and it runs whatever is indented so
here's our colon and here's our indent
python's very big on the indents that's
how it tells what piece of code is
different from the next other languages
use different uh like a semicolon for
java if you're in html you have to put a
block at the beginning at the end so
every different scripting language has
its own setup and this is how python
does it you do an indent right there so
make sure you're very careful where your
indents are and then let's go ahead and
just do enter number and if you can do
an if statement we can also have else
statement and the else occurs print a so
if i wanted to know if this is even or
odd we could do this i could do if a
divided by 2 the remainder of that is
not equal to zero then this is going to
be what odd so this is an odd number
this is an even number just some basic
logic there and if we run this i can now
come down here enter in four it says
four is an even number and then this is
what happens next and we can also do
this if i enter in a 5 5 this is an odd
number so just some basic logics you can
see right here either it is even either
it is odd the remainder is not equal to
2 else whatever whatever's next and the
only other option is it's even now this
may be good if you're just doing a
simple you have two choices we can also
do the l if statement and we put that in
before the else statement l if and then
of course we have our logic here and
we'll go ahead and combine some logic
we're going to do a couple things here
let's go back up to this enter a number
a copy and enter a number we'll have a
number a b
and c so we'll go ahead and have three
different choices take out this last
line and so the first choice we want to
know is is a the greatest value so we
could do a is greater than b
and a is greater than c so if a is
greater than a and a is greater than b a
is the greatest number so we have this
over here and if we have that we have l
f we can do let's say b b is greater
than a and b is greater than c we'll go
ahead and do this we'll do a print
statement print b b is the greatest
number and if a is not the greatest
number and b is not the greatest number
that leaves one other option so go down
to our else statement and we'll have
else c is the greatest number and if we
run this code here we enter a number
we'll enter a one two three and it says
three is the greatest number and of
course if we run this code again you do
three two one it gives me an error
because i accidentally hit a character
string there three two thirty 2. so if
we do this and we do 3 2 1 we still get
3 as the greatest number and finally we
could put it right in the middle and it
should still pull it out we could do 1 3
2 and they'll still come up with 3 is
the greatest number you can actually go
take this as far as you want so we have
just here the three choices you could
have if else if else there are other
ways to do that when you get more than
here but for basic python this covers
most of the program you're doing with
the else and the elsif statement as far
as the logic statements involved in
there the last thing we want to really
look at is a nested if and else
statement and we can do that we'll keep
the get rid of some of this
stuff on the screen clear our screen
here and we can do is we can go enter
let's do enter
your age and we'll call the variable age
up here so we're going to enter the age
and we want to know oh let's say this is
are you available for a certain discount
maybe it's a bus fare discount maybe
it's you get a discount for a restaurant
or something like that so we have here
we enter your age and if a let's do a is
greater than 64. so if a is greater than
64 we put our colon in there and this is
actually age print i will print you are
eligible for senior citizen discount and
maybe we'll be a little nice we'll make
it if you're greater than 60. how about
greater than or equal to 60. we're
really feeling generous so if your age
is greater than or equal to 60 you get a
discount else we'll print you are not
eligible for a discount we'll go and
just run this real quick and so if you
are 66 he'll come up you're eligible for
a discount and if you put in 40 it will
say you're not eligible for a discount
and then we come along we realize oh hey
we have discount also for people who are
under a certain age we have our youth
discount so we'll go ahead and come in
here and we'll say oh if your age is
less than 18 let's do less than or equal
than 19. less than or equal to 18 print
and then of course we can do see you are
eligible for
a minor discount or youth discount and
then we need to come up here if we want
to do this if age is less than 18 since
it's nested we'll do an else here and if
i put the else down here a couple things
to notice about this list so we have our
first statement if age is greater than
or equal to 60 you're eligible for a
senior citizen discount and then we put
the else so any logic whatever happens
under this else this is always going to
go if i move this else back out it'll
give me an error because you can't have
two else states and certainly you could
do this as an lf statement here too so
this is kind of another way of doing an
lf statement sometimes you want to add
some let's put a note here sometimes you
might have additional script here so
before you can do these two calculations
you might have to do some kind of
calculation here that's why you want to
do a nested if and else statement
instead of using the if alif and else
statement and we can see here if i run
this enter your age now if you enter the
age 9 you are eligible for a minor
discount and of course at what we did
before we have somebody who's 56 you are
not eligible for any discount and of
course if you're 64 or 60 or older you
get that nice senior citizen discount
and if you were listening to earlier no
i don't qualify for the senior citizen
discount quite yet although i do look
forward to it the next thing we want to
start covering is our loops and we have
the while and for loop and so the while
loop utilizes your logic to let it know
when to how how many times to loop
through let's go ahead and take a look
and see what that script comes out as we
can do is let's go ahead and take a word
equals to oh let's do python since
that's what we're programming in and
let's do i equals zero let's say while i
is less than or equal to five and since
this is we use that indent just like we
did the ifl statement we still need that
indent in the colon there while i is
less than or equal to five let's go
ahead and print word and then we're
going to do i if you remember correctly
we're going to increment it by one we
can do a plus equals one same as i
equals i plus one so i plus equals one
and if we run this we'll come down here
and you'll see it repeats the python in
this case five times and we can even do
something like this let's do i comma
word and let's run that and you'll see
we get zero one two three four five one
of the things always to be aware of is
we did i is less than or equal to five
if this was an actual length of the
array you would have array out of bounds
because remember you don't want to
include the length of the array because
it's zero to four so a lot of times just
remember unless you actually wanted to
print 0 through 5 we can do while i is
less than 5 print i i plus or equals 1
and then we get our 0 1 2 3 4 python now
there's other ways to do a loop like
this and i'll show you in just a minute
with the for loop this just gives you an
idea here's our true false statements
and just like we did before you could
have if i is less than five or i is less
than eight which would kind of be
redundant but you could have your or and
and you could have a very lengthy logic
gate right here long as it returns true
or false so we use the while because we
don't know how many loops you want to go
through on here in this case we actually
set it to 5. but maybe we're building a
list and let's just go ahead and do this
we'll do a list and create an empty list
let's get an input and we'll uh we'll
call it c and it says enter 1 to add
elements to list and 0 to exit loop the
while loop we've created a
variable and then an enter here and the
input if you remember correctly we're
not converting this to an integer so
we're going to just go ahead and keep it
as a
character so we're going to say while c
does not equal and because it's a
character we got to go ahead and put the
brackets around it to let it know it's
going to be a string the string of 0. so
long as this doesn't equal 0 keep doing
and then we're going to do here on our
while loop is we're going to have
another input here and on here we're
going to have input enter an element to
add to the list that's the input integer
this one isn't it we'll just keep it as
a great input i kind of like that keep
it uniform on there and what we can do
let me just go ahead and copy this up
here so we're going to start adding
elements and the order in which we do
this is always important you never know
how your loop's going to go i switched
that around because i want to append to
my list c so whatever we enter in on the
first one gets appended to the list and
then we ask for the next one if the next
one is a zero so whatever we type in
there is going to be added to the
element and the order as i was saying is
important because if we put this after
the second input whatever you put in
here is going to ignore and if we put it
before that's going to keep adding it in
until you put 0 in the 0 if you put this
after the 0 it will still add the 0 in
so you'll end up with a 0 at the end of
the list so by putting it before this
input we're going to have both the first
input going in and whatever input we add
in and to get a view of what this looks
like let's go ahead and print our list
when we run that you'll see it comes up
it says enter 0 to quit and other to add
to list but i can add an a in we can add
a three in a t remember i didn't put any
bounds on it making it an integer or
anything like that and i'll put the zero
and when i put the zero there it is a
three and t so this while loop keeps
going until it hits something that says
okay we're done and then it just kicks
it out so it finishes the loop comes
back up here says is this true if it's
true we do it again if it's false then
we skip out of the loop and then it
continues on down below where we printed
the list now if you remember from
earlier we had the i plus one and we
just looped through to print python out
four times certainly there's better ways
to do that instead of adding all that
math in there and we can do that so word
equals let's do python so we can do that
real just simply by doing a for loop
four doesn't require logic we do four
we'll do w in range 10 and let's go
ahead and print w comma word and if i
run this we'll see we have python
printed 10 times let me just take that
down a notch since my screen display
doesn't show up as much so range three
and if you remember from earlier range
does 0 2 3 but doesn't include 3. i
could just as easily put 0 comma 3 in
here and i'll get the same answer and
you can also add a step on there there's
a lot of controls you can add with range
so we can print w range of three and
that's pretty cool just prints word over
and over and over again what we can also
do with this is we can create a list so
i can create my list there's our square
brackets and we can do one two
let's add hello we'll add a sub list
which is one two three and so we can do
on this is i could do instead of a range
i could do
object in list so for object and list i
want to print just the object and if we
run this you'll see down here we have
one two hello and then it printed the
one the sub list the whole sub list in
there one two three because that's one
object in there so it just iterates
through each entity in the list and
prints it right out what we can do next
is we can kind of combine some of these
so you've seen the for loop we have our
if statements along with some different
logic gates we can do so we can do let's
do this let's go word equals input and
let's do enter word so we're going to
get a word from you off of your keyboard
let's do count equals zero and we're
just going to count vowels we're going
to use the loop to count the number of
vowels in word so for i n word remember
from before we can iterate through each
object and when you do a string so if we
have if our word was equal python we
have p-y-t-h-o-n
each one of those is an object in that
list that's an actual list so we enter
the word that's a list of letters so
this is just going to go through and
look at each one of those letters and
we're going to say hey if i'm in it
we'll give it an array if it's a e i o u
or capital a capital e capital i capital
o capital u these are seen differently
they're very different characters on
there we have our
our colon here this lets us know we need
to indent at this point we know it's a
val so we want to go ahead and count
plus equals one and then we just want to
go down here and say uh print number of
vowels in
oh let's do a little formatting s is the
if remember we got to create that little
tuple at the end with all the different
values and so here is our word
and our count so let's go ahead and run
this and for the word i'll go ahead and
enter in count and we can see the number
of vowels in count is two and sure
enough it's got an ou in it and if we
run this again and let's do counting we
can see that there's three vowels in
there oh you and i now when we're
talking about loops both the while loop
and the for loop and this works actually
on any the continuum break will work any
kind of indent so even the if statement
i can add a break part way through the
if statement and it will kick it out so
it's important to know but we want to
know about break and continue and how
those work so let's go ahead and create
a little script here so we can take a
look at it and break is just like you
think it is whatever it's doing it it
stops it it breaks the flow so let's go
ahead and do this we're going to do a
range
two comma the integer of n divided by
two plus one we're gonna look for a
prime numbers let's see if we can figure
out how to find a prime number and so
what we have going here is i'm going to
take n which equals 49. and to help me
find the prime number we're going to go
all the way through let's see in range 2
to n divided by 2. we're going to add 1
to it now for the first part we don't
really need to add the one but i'm going
to show you in a minute that for another
piece of code we can put the one in so
i'm just going to leave that in there
and we're going to just divide by each
of those i's so i is equal to 2 3 4 5 6
all the way up to 25 so it's basically 2
to 25 and we want to take the the and we
want to divide by that but we want to
know if there's a remainder that's how
we can tell if it's a prime number
because if it has no remainder then we
have a prime number so n divided by i
the remainder of it if that equals 0
then this is not a prime number so we'll
print this is not a prime number and
instead of
this is we'll just go ahead and do oh
let's just do something simple n is not
a prime number there we go now if we
picked a number like 20 it will get to
four and print this is not a prime
number it'll get to five this is not a
prime number it will get to ten this is
not a prime number it's going to print
that three times we don't want it to
keep printing that we want to stop we
want to say hey we got an answer it's
not a prime number break and if we go
ahead and run this we should get 49 is
not a prime number it's divisible by 7.
we do know that oh the number 11 is a
prime number so if i run this it'll just
go through the code and say okay we're
good this is the kind of thing you might
do if you have an input and you're
checking the input to make sure they're
valid inputs you want to come up and say
hey this isn't a valid input kick it out
or if it's a valid input go ahead and do
the process on there and if you're going
to have break we also need to look at
continue and how that works and so let's
say instead of looking for a prime
number i want to know all the different
numbers that divide into the number i
want to know what it's divisible by and
so we can do that let's do if it's not
equal to then divided by i is not equal
to zero i want it to continue um else
what i want to do is i want to print
let's do our place marker we'll do d
is visible by this is also going to be a
number so we'll do another d for decimal
then of course if you do this part we're
going to have our tuple on the end and
in this case we want to do our number n
is divisible by our number i so let's
take a look and see what's going on with
this code continue unlike just says hey
here we have our loop or it could be a
while statement for statement so here we
have our loop i get to here and it says
okay if this remainder does not equal
zero i don't want to do anything after
this i just want to go back to the top
of the loop and so it skips this line
down here it's like an else statement
right here else do this so this is one
way you can almost put an else statement
here instead so i can run this and it
says process finished because 11 happens
to be a prime number we'll set it to 20
since i brought up that earlier and
we'll see that 20 is dividable by 2.
it's divisible by 4. it's divisible by 5
by 10. it just goes right down the list
and so this gives you an idea of how you
can utilize the continue when you're in
one of these loops to use that logic to
help you get the script to do what you
want it to do the next topic we want to
cover is going to be some more advanced
modules as you get more and more
advanced in python you really are
starting to look at all these great
modules that are developed by third
parties one of the greatest drinks in
python is you get a module to do almost
anything and two of the modules we want
to look at are arrays and numpy these
are in data science they're so important
for storing information and manipulating
it and the difference between an array
because we have remember we did lists
remember lists from before our list they
equal within the brackets and a lot of
times you'll you might have caught me
once or twice hopefully you didn't but
you probably did or i call the list an
array in python they're not the same
thing that's very important to note
because a list is a base python list of
objects where the array is a special
module you bring in and you've got to be
careful when you're talking about other
programming languages an array is what a
list is in python so you might hear that
terminology they probably have some
other programming languages and they do
have a lot of similarities so we're
going to do from array import star so
we're going to import everything we have
from the array setup that's all this
means so from our array we're importing
all the different sub modules in it you
could probably just get by with import
array at this point because that would
do a similar thing but we will let you
know that there is a difference there
and we do an array we just use the array
command code and then we can create the
array inside the brackets and just like
a list we can do all kinds of things
with this as far as mix and match but
one of the nice things about array i can
also tell it it has to be of a specific
type so in this array here i'm
designating these are all integers sent
to it a list of integers one two three
four five and if we print the type of
the array you should see it come down
here and it says okay class array array
has finished so the class is always
going to be an array on here and this
particular array might designate it as
integers we can also do on our print
just like you have like your regular
array you can access the integers by
their index number so we'll put in two
if we print the array of index two we'll
see that it points to three so it's just
like a list so far so far it has all the
different setups you would as a list on
here and this includes append so i could
actually take this and i could go um
array append minus 10. we'll run that
just print out the whole array and we'll
see now we have an array of type i one
two three four five minus ten something
just a pin just like we did so in other
words all the functionality you have on
your list you're gonna find you have
with the array we'll just go ahead and
do a couple more like that so you can
see what that looks like let's go ahead
and remove three so if i remove the
value three from here you'll see one two
four five minus 10. if we want to go
ahead and print when you saw i printed
the index the first time we can also do
an actual index minus 10 on the array
let's go ahead and run that and we get
4. this is kind of interesting because
if i did this with a list i would get an
error by doing the index minus 10. so we
have minus 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 and it
just kind of loops over until it gets to
the 3. but where arrays are different
than lists and this is so important this
is what makes an array an array we'll
take this back here and just print the
array on here i can do something like
this ar equals ar
times three and if i run this you'll see
right here my array has now jumped and
so when i do ar times three the array is
now two four five minus 10 and it
repeats it three times so this is one of
the cool things you can do with an array
on here now at this point if you're
doing a lot of functionality on your
array you'll almost always end up in
numbers python so even though there's a
lot of really cool things especially the
type settings so you can actually have
it all integers really in this
particular module you want numpy which
sits on top of array and probably the
most common form you see it you'll see
import numpy as np now you can just do
import numpy and wherever you see np you
use numpy now if you are you'll see when
i run this i get an error because i
opened up a new project in pi chart that
means all my modules that are added in
externally aren't there if you are
working
ide you might go to the command line and
do a pip install
numpy and that will bring it in if
you're using pip there's a number of
different install packages if you're
using jupiter notebooks under conda or
anaconda it's conda install conda does
the same thing as pip except that it
brings in all the different sub packages
pip's the most common one your pip
install but we're in python pi charm and
so in pycharm we want to go up to click
on that file once we're on file we want
to go down to settings once we're under
settings we want to go under our project
and then you'll see project interpreter
this is really cool that we're actually
in here because you can see underneath
here we're using python 36 so if i had a
rollout in a different version i could
go in here and add those versions in and
switch them around i just have the one
on this particular machine and i go over
here to the plus sign on the right hand
side and i click on there and then for
installing in here we'll type in numpy
and once i have numpy you'll see uh
there's the different versions of numpy
on here generally you want to ignore all
of those unless you're doing something
special and go right to the one that's
just straight numpy and then click on
install package then pycharm will take
over it will install the numpy package
into this particular environment this is
when the beautiful things about using
pie charm is it keeps this environment
separate from everything else and then
once it's installed we can now go back
close out of here out of settings and
there's our numpy added in there so now
it shows me what i have installed on
here this is such a great tool because i
can see exactly what i'm using in this
environment and now when i run it you'll
see i don't get an error for not having
the module so you got to make sure the
numpy module is installed and this
really is if you're doing data science
one of the bread and butter tools you
need is your numpy setup your numpy
array and we'll go ahead and create our
first numpy array we'll call it ar one
equals np dot array so np for numpy dot
array is the command oh let's just do
one two three i guess i'm being a little
boring as far as what i'm putting in it
and then let's go ahead and just print
that and see what that looks like print
this is an array made with a list
there's other ways to make an array but
we're just going to print our ar1 we put
a list in there so we just doesn't need
a list into it and then we print our ar1
and we see that it comes out it looks
just like a list one of the catches is
there's no commas in here so if i wanted
to go ahead and let's say
take our list you're going to say why is
this so important there's no commas in
there if you're doing a lot of debugging
and you see this first one you know
you're either in an array or list if you
see the next one you know you're in
numpy so it's just kind of a quick flag
in the programming script and debugging
for some of the things you can look for
now the numpy array starts to take a
major shift here this is where this
becomes real important as far as the
setup we'll talk about shape and sizes
and matrixes here in just a second but
let's go ahead and do this we're going
to create two sub lists so remember that
from before we have list one list two
i'm going to do that i do need to put
brackets around it this is a 2d
sample and you can look at this as being
one of the common things is x y
coordinate so i might have 1 2 3 for x 4
5 6 for y and if we print that out you
can see as it comes down here printer
ar1 it prints it out no commas but you
have your two different lists on here
and we can do something like this we can
print dimensions equals and then i'm
going to do ar2 dot in dimensions so if
we run this you'll see it comes out with
i have a print or set up on there and it
has two dimensions and that's pretty
easy to see we have dimension one which
is a one two three in dimension two
which is four five six likewise there's
also size and shape and so if i
do this set up on here we can see that
we can get the size dimensions is two
the size is six just how many entities
are in there and then the shape this is
i don't know how many times i look at
the shape of these things because you're
putting it through some kind of format
and if your shapes don't match when
you're doing machine learning and you're
doing a fit and a train you'll get an
error and so it's so important to double
check your shape and make sure it's
correct make sure we have a two by three
matrix in this case and then finally
just like you can do this with any of um
you know type command we can also get
the what they call d type in numpy so in
your number array we'll see that the
type of elements is an integer 32 so it
actually returns what kind of elements i
have in here and they do they all look
like integers on there let's go ahead
and take a short detour here and just
take a look at the
numpy official site so if we go to the
official numpy site we'll see right off
the top scipy.org which is the group
behind it it's all open source you can
actually go in here and donate to it and
it is so extensive i'm just going to
look at data types and so data types
gets its own tab and you can see from
here we were what integer there's so
many specialties you can do with this
and so they cover just about every data
type you can think of there's our
integer 32. so here's our integer 32
that is the standard that's usually what
it converts to if you're converting from
directly from python into numpy but you
can force it into any of these other
different kind of data types on here so
it has a lot of diverse use on this
obviously we can't cover everything
under numpy there's array creation
input output with numpy indexing
broadcasting byte swapping structured
arrays each one of these is a
significantly large topic it's its own
class if you will uh you can see right
here we're going to do that we'll try to
cover just a couple things so you get a
little flavor of numbie uh so let's take
a look at we have our numpy stuff going
on let's go ahead and look at filling an
array with zeros this comes up because
sometimes you want zero as your
placeholder and so you begin your
process with filling it with zeros or
ones or other values and you can simply
do np dot zeros and then this is
important is it needs to know the
dimensions we'll do it two by two and
we'll do a d type equals there's our
integer so we're going to fill it as
integers on here let's go ahead and take
our z and if we print this out and run
that you'll see that i get a nice two by
two array filled with zero so maybe i'm
doing plotting i don't know what the
plots are but i need to have it
pre-filled yeah a lot of test data does
this you can create your own data and
make stuff up and do all kinds of things
there once you have it pre-formatted and
if we fill it with zeros we can also do
fill it with almost anything so instead
of zeros we'll do a full and let's do
two comma three and then instead of
let's just do fill it with
let's do one and let's run this and when
i run this you'll see that i've created
a two by three array all filled with
ones and just like our list and
everything else we can come in here and
we can access the different indexes of
our numpy array in this case we're going
to do index one comma two and when i run
that we get six where does one comma two
come from well remember we count from
zero so there's zero one and we count
from zero we get zero one two and so if
we do this arrangement one comma two is
going to be the row followed by the
column and just like any of these we can
get very complicated we can do something
like this we'll keep this as one and we
could also do so we'll do one we have
our comma but i want to do after the
comma a colon there then i'm going to
put in another colon and if you remember
from before that means we're going to do
a step and let's do minus 1. so this
would look a little familiar this is the
same kind of format you got from list
and if i run this we're going to look at
the 1 so 0 1 4 5 6. i'm going to select
all of them that's what the first colon
is and then the second one says hey but
i want to go backwards we're going to
step minus one and so we're going six
five four on here that's why you get the
six five four and we could also do
something like this we could add in 2 1
and if we run that
you'll see that i get 3 2 1 because it
doesn't include 1. if you do up to 2 and
then we get 3 2 1 6 5 4. so now we have
that the first two in reverse 0 and 1.
and you can just play with this
different ways to select different
entities in our numpy array and although
we can't dig into all the different
aspects of a numpy array i did want to
bring up one last thing which is
operations on a numpy array this is
pretty cool because i can take this and
here's our numpy array we've created we
can do something like this we can take
print array 3 and let's just add 10 to
it and this is a little different than
what we've seen before so if i run this
and i add 10 to it we run it you'll see
it adds 10 to every entity in the array
so i have 11 12 13 14 15 16 and so on
just adding 10 on there and likewise i
could do all kinds of different values
like times 10 so there it is multiplied
out by times 10. there is other
functionality like you can sum it so we
can sum all the values in there you
could also select just a slice of this
so you could select let's do the first
zero and then sum it and so we get six
one plus two plus three is six so
there's some there's min there's max the
slew of commands just goes on and on and
on there's so much you can do with the
numpy array and some important things to
note there's also what they call
transpose
and this comes in a lot when you're
graphing because you might have a graph
that looks at x y let's go back to our
2d array and it wants all of x y but
your array came in as all the rows so
you have one comma four two comma five
three comma six and you need to
transpose it if i run this you'll see
that i've gone from one two three comma
four five six to one four two five three
six tends to be the other way around
there's times when you need the
individual pairs and of course we could
go back and transpose it going the other
way of course this doesn't work because
when you do this it doesn't do it in
place you have to let it know it's in
place if you're going to do that that's
we'd have to do something more like ar
3 equals ar transpose take this t out
and now we should get it where it flips
it from the original values to 1 4 2 5 3
6 and back again so we can move the data
back and forth and transpose that back
and forth quite easily with this uh so
we touched a little bit upon the basics
understanding of numpy that's a really
powerful tool we need to move on and
look at functions functions are so
important in python they're kind of
programmers bread and butter
so let's do a function just call this a
fun and in our fun i wanted to print
simply learn so what i'm doing is i'm
creating a function that allows me to
call this piece of script whenever i
want so instead of having the loop do
this i now have the function do this and
instead of maybe i have this function
where i want to print simply learn them
at five different places in my program
instead of retyping it i can just wrap
it all up in a wrapper function wrapper
and we can simply just call this the way
you call it is you just type in the name
fun because that's the name of our
function a little confusing there for
fun simply learn is fun i like that kind
of combination and if we run this you'll
see it just simply prints simply learn
because this function executes
whatever's in this indent and you can
see right here is our diff that's it no
it's a definition the name of our
function and then a set of brackets
right here now if we want to do
something and you know it's exciting
just be able to print something maybe we
want to add two numbers and let's go
ahead and do a comma b we can now put
these numbers in these brackets and this
function now sees these numbers in here
and we go ahead and print oh let's is
print a plus b and i'm gonna do come
down here and go
add and we'll do five four comma five
we'll run that and if we run that you
see four plus five equals nine well we
might not wanna just run it we might
want to actually have a value come out
of it and so instead we'll do s for
summation equals a plus b and then i
want to return this value so now i can
come over here and i can do we'll just
call n for number
equals add four comma five and if we
print in you'll see this whole process
now brings it all together so now i have
my function i'm sending it a comma b
it's going to add a comma b and it's
going to return the results for that and
then i get that under my end so i set
this variable equal to that and i print
in and something i want to point out is
that this return s
is a tuple and we'll talk about that
again in just a minute or let's why not
we'll just go ahead and do that now so
we have our summation and then we might
have the difference what's the
difference between a minus b minus b and
i'm going to leave this just as n so you
can see what that looks like but we're
going to return s comma d the difference
sum and difference and if i print it out
you'll see that it returns nine that's
our s and d is a minus one and it's in a
tuple form uh so s comma d returns this
nice tuple we can also instead of doing
this i could do n one comma and two and
then we can print n one comma n two uh
and we did this earlier we are assigning
variables it's the same thing but
instead of assigning this in one comma
n2 equal to whatever they are nine comma
minus one we're having it return from
our function so it comes right out there
and then we can print the two different
values and then this is kind of an
interesting thing we can come up here
and preset our values going in and
instead of a i'm sending it four comma
five i'm gonna say a equals one b equals
three let's do the other way around
let's go five if i run this now remember
last time we sent it four five and i got
nine minus one now i'm sending it four
five and i still get the nine minus one
but if i take this out and i don't send
it any values it'll automatically
default to the a equals five and b
equals three and then we get our eight
two you know five plus three is eight
five minus three is two so we've covered
a lot so far as far as the basic
definition sending it information
returns it as a tuple one of the tricks
you can do is a star args they call them
args and quarks and we're going to talk
a little bit about what the difference
is between args and quarks they are
designated with the asterisks so this is
args now i don't have to call it ours i
could call it my args that is not
specific to the program and we can just
go ahead and print i always like to do
lowercase for the first letter and then
when i change names uppercase and that's
just kind of a python standardization
for naming your different variables and
if i print my args we can come back down
here and i can do let's just call this
call this ak for args and quarks oh
spell it out args args underscore
there we go and so if i go down here and
i go hey let's uh call my function paste
that down here and we'll come in here
and i'm going to put in one two three
four it might be i don't know how many
values i have going in i just know that
i have a bunch of values that are going
to come in and i know what order they're
in and so you can see right here it
takes my args we print out my args and i
typed in one two three four and that's
what comes in and we could do something
like this we could print args of
one because maybe that's a specific
setup and it'll print two one is the
twos in the one place that's our index
and if we're doing like addition we
could do something like
c equals my args 0 minus let's do
addition plus
my args one and you can guess on here if
we return call it a we can come down
here and do
a equals args of korgs and then if i
print our a and i run this
you can see it comes up with three
because one plus two equals three and it
might be that you only do stuff if three
and four exist let's just do it this way
well this is fine so you can see right
here that we can now send it whatever
args i want and it will do those in a
list so i could send significantly more
values in here than is up here and
that's okay and that's how your args
work again the asterisk so where does
quarks come in what does kw args mean
well instead of my args let's go star
star let's go astro gastric or star star
my kw args and let's just go ahead and
take a look and see what these look like
let's print them out grab this variable
up here and again it's the double
asterisks this lets us know that this is
a core and down here where i'm calling
my my definition i'm going to go ahead
and change this up and i'm going to say
a equals 10 and b equals 20. and then we
have return a let's just take the return
a out for right now and just have a
print it and if i run this you'll see it
comes up with a 10 b 20. we haven't
talked about dictionaries we didn't
cover dictionaries yet it's a special
kind of set and the way the dictionary
works is you have your index or key and
it has a value and the index or key is
immutable you can't change it you can
delete it you can add it but you can't
change it and you can change the in
value and so you can see right here we
have an index of a and an index of b and
so i could also do print my works and
instead of doing 0 i can now do a and
we'll do addition i'll do plus my quarks
and b hit the wrong button there okay
plus mike works a b and if we run this
of course you got to make sure this is a
string the a value here is definitely a
string coming in we can do print my
quarks of a plus my quarks of b and you
can see that we get 10 plus 20 equals
30. so this is just a really cool way to
send information to your function and
have it be able to like you might have
all kinds of stuff in here you need to
send once you send it you can do all
your different processes you can also do
if you remember from before i can do
something like this let's do this if a
in my quarks and e
in my quarks then print my quarks of a
plus my quarks of b and you can see
right here if i change this instead of
two a i can change it to c and run it
and it'll say hey i've got a value of c
i've got a value of b but because i a is
not in there i'm not going to do this
addition so you start to get into some
logic gates that make sure you have the
data you're processing in there and what
you're working on and then one last cool
thing to remember is that our definition
is an object so like any other object
and we'll talk a little bit more about
objects here in a minute i can assign it
to a variable so i can do d equals my
args quarks and then i can do d of i'll
do a equals one comma b equals two and
if i run this and go and run that uh
you'll see our first run which we
already had up here where a c ten b
twenty and then you'll see i write it
again this time it has a equals 1 b
equals 2 and it sums them together as 3.
so you can assign this value you can
assign this whole definition to a
variable the final thing we want to
touch upon with our definition and our
functions is the recursive we've already
discussed the whole reason having a
definition is i can now call it from
multiple times from different parts of
my program so that if i know i need to
add certain numbers together i don't
have to replace this code in every time
i need that i just access my definition
in a single line so recursive means the
program this definition calls itself and
just like the while statement you run
the risk of running an indefinite loop
and of course if you're stuck in a
indefinite loop that will eventually
crash your program you're running and so
we might have we'll call this definition
rec for recursive and we want to take in
and we want to do something with it so
we might say hey if n
equals 1
print in and return
so when we hit the value of one on end
we know this recursive function is done
that's what this is doing but if it
doesn't equal one we might want it to
print in and then
we could do something like this
return
recursive of n minus 1. so let's take a
look and see what's going on here the
first thing it does is it says hey if n
equals 1 we're done with this loop
because it is a loop it's looping in on
itself and what we want to do is we want
to go ahead and print in and then just
return and then we come down here we say
well if it's not equal to 1 we want to
print in and then we want to run this
loop again with n minus one so we're
changing our logic gate here's our n n
keeps changing so n starts off at one
value and we keep subtracting and then
we can just do something like this i can
do let's do a recursive and we'll redo a
3 and we'll run this and i get 3 2 1.
why because each time it goes down here
and it subtracts 1 that goes back into
this then it says okay 3 minus 1 is it
equal to 1 no print it out once we
printed it out do n minus 1 and so on
and you can see right here we just do a
simple countdown certainly there's more
complicated scripts you can write but
you can see how the simple recursive
value works we could use this to solve a
factorial problem let's call this
factorial def fact of n and we'll change
this down here so we call it and run it
and if you remember factorial simply we
take value we want to return call this f
f
equals 1
for i in range let's see would it be in
range of one comma n plus one remember
it doesn't include the last one so we
have to add that extra plus one on there
for our range and we simply do f equals
f we can actually do this the python way
f times equals i uh so f equals f times
i and it just keeps going through and
finds out what all the factorials are
and if we do this return f we can print
our factorial of three there we go and
we run this and we'll get a nice value
six so one times two times three equals
six we could also do this as a recursive
problem just like before we need some
kind of break that says hey we're done
so we'd say if n equals 1. let's just
return 1. if it doesn't equal 1 then
what we want to do is we want to return
the factorial of n minus 1. yeah the
factorial of n minus 1 times n that's
what i want to do so we take the value
we have and we multiply it times the
factorial of n minus 1. so if our value
is 3 we're going to multiply that times
a factorial of 2. and we take 2 we
multiply that times a factorial of 1.
well 1 is one so you're multiplying one
times two and then back again to three
and so if we take out take out this part
right here now we have the same code in
factorial using recursion and it just
goes right down the list right there and
if we run this we'll get the same value
6 just like we expected and i want to go
back a step let's just real quickly go
back to
here there we go for i in range of one f
equals we did the f times equals f or i
so we're going through here and this one
looks pretty good we've gone through and
it adds up the factorial but as a
recursion problem if you remember
correctly this one just goes to the end
we know the exact answer danger of the
recursion one as we go back here and do
a quick undo is it's calling itself and
you can see right here if n equals one
and then just keeps going minus one and
minus one and if i run this we get our
six but what if the value in here is
minus three well we keep subtracting we
go minus 3 minus 4 and so on
you can already see there's going to be
a problem and if i run this
it will crash the program because it
gets stuck in a recursive loop and here
you go it gives me the recursive error
maximum recursive depth exceeded in
comparison so we actually have a limit
on there so you got to be real careful
with your recursive functions but
they're also really useful in handy in a
lot of different scripting and
computations i hate to wrap up on an
error so i'll switch it back to three
and run it so we'll have our nice value
of six
but we wanna talk about next
lambda lambda is a very useful tool and
especially when we get into what they
call mapping and reducing functions
map and reduce itself is a hadoop term
and there's an actual scripting code
called mapreduce but it's also a
programming way of thinking so this is a
very important concept or a number of
important concepts we're going to cover
with the lambda which means function
lambda just is a they call the lambda
function and how and why it works and
how it's used what we're going to do is
we're going to take our add function
from before we had add a b very simple
function to do we have s equals a plus b
return if i run this we'll add the 10
plus 20 on there 30 just like you would
expect it from our previous definitions
the lambda function or its bases is it
actually does all of this in one line of
code so that's the first thing we're
going to start with is our very basic
lambda function
l equals lambda there's our keyword
lambda meaning it's a function a comma b
and we get a plus b and so when you see
this our lambda function i can print l
and then we can do 10 20. this does
exactly what we just did with the add
function it takes the 10 and the 20 it
comes across as a tuple there's our
tuple being sent in the tuple is a b and
then it simply returns a plus b whatever
is on the right hand side so the lambda
is a simple function now we can get
really complicated by using a function
for the function but you can just put
your simple function here a plus b l
equals lambda a comma b colon a plus b
and we get our nice print
l for lambda 10 20. we can also do some
kind of filtering in here so we'll do
let's create ourselves a list here's a
list of letters and let's say i want to
take this list and i want to filter it
out so we'll give it a variable here for
our lambda we'll just use x x is very
commonly used in lambda and then we'll
put over here x in and let's say if you
remember from before when we did the
vowels we had our a e i o u and if we
run this and i go ahead and print l pop
that back in there and run forgot we're
doing a filter function i forgot the
whole of it we're going to do a list and
we're going to do this list of a filter
so we'll need brackets for the list i'll
have my filter and then i'll need
brackets for the filter what's going
into the filter and the filter comes in
here we're going to put the lambda in
there so let's break this down i'm
creating a list
from that list i'm filtering out and i'm
going to use the lambda function and the
lambda function says hey for each entity
in this list i want to know if x is in a
e i o u and if it is in aeiou then at
that point i want to go ahead and add it
to my list and so here we are adding it
on to the lst over filtering the lst and
we're returning the value to go into
this list what you can do is you could
imagine that instead of this being a
list of these it might be a row in your
database you're processing so you have a
lot of data coming in and you can see
right here it filters it out it gets rid
of the b and the f and we end up with
our aeoa it filters it out so imagine
that you're sending it a row in your
database so for each row we want to know
what the the lambda is and it processes
each character in this data this could
easily be an array or columns you know
from your row we might have column a
name first name last name address and
you want to know which one of these is
part of something else so we've covered
a filter what i want to cover next is
mapping and a lot of times when i work
with filters and maps and i'm working
with data the terminology map when
you're thinking map is
everything you can do to one line or one
row in your database you don't need all
the other rows to look at it so mapping
is another tool and the actual uh use of
map with lambda we'll do a result equals
equals map lambda and then we're going
to take each character in there and
we're going to just go ord we're going
to convert it to its ascii code and
we're going to add 1 to it so we're just
going to adjust it to each one and i
forgot and took out my actual list of
course pie charm already remembers it
unless i restart the pie charm
environment so it'd still work if i ran
it so we have our list a b e f o a then
we're going to get a result let's go
ahead and print the result and run it
and you can see right here uh result and
we'll convert it into a list and so when
we print the result we get
bcfgpb i'm guessing you know a the next
one up would be b b the next one up
would be c e the next one up would be f
and so on and again when we're talking
about maps the mapping part of a program
it's whatever you can do on one line of
data and i bring that up and i keep
saying that over and over and over again
because when you touch upon data
processing and especially big data this
is how we're able to cover terror and
terabytes of data is we process one row
at a time and that's the mapping they
call that that is literally the mapping
we are mapping something if i look at
this row of data i don't need to know
anything else about the database other
than this row of data and that's how i'm
going to map it and if you're going to
map something you need to go ahead and
reduce it because if you have a ton of
different rows in a database or whatever
you're working with in this case we're
just working with characters in a list
we want to reduce it to something
everybody can read something you can
process at a glance we do need to go
ahead and import reduce so we'll do that
from the function tools import reduce
that makes it much more legible instead
of doing functionals dot reduce and then
we'll do our results equals reduce
lambda x of y x plus the y of our list
and all we're saying here is for each
element that we look at we're going to
divide this up and then we're just going
to keep adding it on to our list and
then if we print out the result we run
it you'll see we end up with a b e f o a
and that's from the original list
remember this lambda result is not fed
into here this is the list that's being
fed into here in fact let's go ahead and
remove the map i'm going to keep the map
up there and reduce so we mapped it and
then we take so we're processing each
individual character in our map we're
processing each individual character in
this list changing it tacking it onto
the list it returns the differences and
then we're going to bring them all
together so we're doing a reduction
reducing it into one string down here so
we've covered a lot we've had our
functions so we looked at our lambda the
next thing we want to look at is modules
and we've already been looking at that
without even knowing it and we'll start
with i'm going to call this i renamed
this one
mod1.py this is stuff we already did
earlier so we had our prime of a our
even number of a def prime of a equals
4i and range 2 comma a if the remainder
of a divided by i equals 0 print numbers
not prime return number is prime and
then we also did even print number is
even print number is odd so this is
something we did earlier we created
these definitions to let us know whether
it's even or odd i've changed the name
to mod 1 dot py and this is going to be
saved in the same folder as our scratch
so this script that i'm going to write
in here is in the same folder you can
also put it in your library so if you
have your environment and you have all
your library folders which has all the
other default python including the
modules we imported this will access
either one and what we can simply do on
this is we can now import our mod one
and so we can do from mod one import
everything so that's gonna import our
two definitions it's gonna import prime
and it's gonna
import even and so anything we do in
here can now access that so we can now
do n equals integer let's do an enter
input
and enter number so we're going to have
it input a number and it's going to
force it to be an integer so now we have
our n and we'll simply do print and
let's take a look over here we had from
our module we had print prime of a or
even of a those are our two options on
there that's what we had brought in so i
can do print prime and we're going to
send in back there and i can also do
print or actually there's no prints
there's no return statement so it's just
prime of n and even of n so those are
the two things we imported and if we run
that it's going to ask me to enter a
number we'll enter in 3 or 23 in this
case and you'll say number is prime
number is odd so 23 is a prime number
and it's also an odd number it's an even
rod this could be very complicated
because you could also do you know add a
select in here run this if i have a
selection of a or b or whatever but at
this point you're now writing modules
for your script and you can see how you
can easily organize a very lengthy
program by having your different modules
built outside of what you're working on
so you're not you don't have this huge
length of like hundreds of lines of code
to read through you only have the little
piece you're working on and you can
share these modules that way if you're
working as a group just like we imported
math you know very or numpy numpy as np
we can now share these modules with
other people who can then utilize them
for their projects let's go ahead and
close out of this and clear up my area
of i'm working with and we're going to
jump into the next big topic that is not
meaning that i just knocked my coffee
over and spilled it all over my desk but
object oriented programming and we're
going to start with the theory there's a
lot of theory behind oops it's been
around for since the 90s very central to
just about any programming language out
there and earlier when i pointed out
that your functions we do the def
statement def whatever your function
name is that those are objects we can
actually set them to variables and so
object oriented programming is what this
is all centered on we have an object
everything in python is an object if you
look at it programming paradigm that
focuses on objects every instance in
python is an object so like i just said
everything you do in python you have an
object you're looking at an object has
attributes so we have data that
describing the object and it has
behavior methods on the attributes these
are your definitions your functions and
your tributes are your your list your
arrays your numpy array your variables
all those are attributes and so for
example if we have a bmw i don't drive a
bmw myself i actually have a beatable
pickup truck given where i live i would
prefer my trip pickup truck to the bmw
but if i live someplace else i would
definitely like a nice bmw to drive
around so for an example you have a year
manufacturer maximum speed those are all
attributes of your bmw and for behavior
you might have you might display the
speed because the speed's always
changing so there you go those are all
behavior as you accelerate the amount of
gas going into the engine changes as you
push on the brake you're pushing on the
brake is a behavior and is changing the
speed of the car so we define a class
class is a collection of similar objects
so for example a car we have bmw we have
ford we have an audi the inheritance
mechanism for a new class to use the
features of another class so we have a
number of different things inheritance
we might have our class which is
vehicles and then under vehicles we
might have cars cars inherits all the
different stuff from vehicles so we have
inheritance so you can create a class
from another class the feature
preventing data from direct access is
called encapsulation so when we have our
object programming we have integers we
looked at integers you can't actually
access integer you assign a variable
that has all the different features and
functions of an integer but you don't
access the actual integer object you can
but generally you don't you have it
encapsulated so that it's never altered
and polymorphism is a feature of using
the same function in multiple ways so
you can think of this in in our example
of vehicles and cars we might also have
vehicles and bicycles well bicycles
accelerate very different than a car
does a car you step on the gas a bicycle
you step on the pedal both of them have
a similar acceleration you want to
polymorph that function so that it works
the same for both of those but it does
something very different so let's go
ahead and create our class and we'll
call it car we have our semicolon here
which says that whatever comes after
this is indented as part of the class
car now there's some things we're
leaving out here you'll almost always
see brackets and variables in there
we'll look at that in just a moment
let's just start with the class car and
we might have car type must give it an
attribute this particular attribute is a
car type and we'll set it equal to
manual and this is a global variable
we've set up on here that's used
throughout the setup throughout the
class car and then we want to create a
def and this is a very special
definition remember that's a function
for diff and we call it init it stands
for initialize and we put a double
underscore before it and a double score
underscore after it what that means is
when i create this class an instance of
the class not the class itself but i
create this instance of this class i
create a variable equal to car this
initializes it and self means that it's
referring to itself whenever you see
self in the class you're referring to
that instance and we'll look at that a
little bit more closer in just a minute
so hopefully if you're confused we'll be
able to help you with that we'll go
ahead and give it past a couple
variables speed so when we initiate
class we're going to pass it year and
speed and then self is just part of the
what's passed into the definition and
we'll go and do self dot year equals
year and
self.speed equals speed so up here we
have a global variable and down here we
have an instance feature i use variable
and feature kind of interchangeably but
certainly feature is probably the more
appropriate word but they are variables
also either way they're the same thing
and then let's go ahead and create a
what's called a static method and you
set it that by doing the at symbol here
and we'll call it static method this is
a command it lets us know that this is
not specific to an object or the classes
variable so this is independent of our
specific initiation and with this we're
going to do welcome and we'll just have
it do a print down here we'll go print
oh welcome to the car showroom kind of
fun there so here's our so i forgot to
put the uh def in front of welcome this
is tabbed in so when we do this when i
have our instance this never changes
it's a static method it's always going
to do the same thing it doesn't matter
where it's coming from it doesn't need
to access any other information in the
any other features in the class car or
in whatever initiated variable i have
and then we'll do something a little bit
more traditional def get speed
automatically does the self and in this
case we're just going to do print
maximum
speed is
self dot speed now remember we initiated
it so here's our self dot speed self
means it's the instance we're creating
it's not the actual class but the
instance and we're going to print that
out and so let's take a look at that and
just see how this all comes together i
did forget one piece of the of the
puzzle just like we have a static method
i'm going to do this up here we also
have what's called class specific so
when you have a class specific method
you denote that with class method now
remember the static method doesn't care
anything about what's in the class it
doesn't care about the initiation it has
all the information it needs with the
class method we need to go ahead and use
have information this class specific and
we did that up here when i did class and
i did car type equals manual so that's
the feature that we can access
underneath this title and we'll create a
definition here and we'll call this type
we'll just do cls because it's a class
method that's what the cls stands for
and then we're going to do print we're
in a nice showroom and we say these cars
are comma
cls.car type so the cls just refers to
the class class are variables without
the self in front so when i have a class
or a feature underneath class any
instance i create is going to have car
type equals manual where when i initiate
it and i have self any feature like
self.year self.speed is going to be just
that instance has that feature whatever
value we put into it and then we have a
static method which only accesses the
static method it doesn't have any other
information coming into it from either
the class or external and then you can
see here we have type class denoted by
cls and we can print the class type and
then we have the self there's our self
our most basic definition get speed and
the way this works is we have our bm
let's do our here's our bmw so our bmw
equals make sure there's no spaces in
front of it it's going to equal car and
we have our car class back up here yeah
i did it all lower case a lot of times
car the class is you want to start with
a capital letter you don't have to but
that just is like a kind of a programmer
standard on there so you can remember
that it is a class versus a variable
which we start with lowercase and if you
go up here to initial we have self which
it automatically sends because this is a
part of the car and then we have year
and speed and so we want to go ahead and
send those in there we're going to
2018 and we'll say has a maximum speed
of 155. i don't usually living where i
do i don't go over
75 or 80 at the tops due to the
particular laws we have and we'll do a
forward in this particular ford on their
showroom what are 2016 and maybe your
ford has a maximum speed of 140. so now
we've created two instances and if i do
bmw dot get
speed you'll see here that it doesn't
the self which i put in here isn't
needed because it already pulls itself
in that is the the instance it's saying
the bmw which i called it is pulling in
bmw on here and all the features with
self are pulled into it also so if i run
this
you'll see down here that it pulls up
the speed it says maximum speed is 155
for bmw and let's say we want to know
about the ford maybe we'll do
ford get speed and we run this and the
maximum speed for the ford is 140. and
of course we're looking at the little
ticker tape of the car and along comes
the guy who says hey do you want to buy
a car and we'll do the car welcome and
if we run that it says messed up on this
because it's a capital c there we go and
we do the car welcome it says welcome to
the car showroom maximum speed is 140 on
the car you're looking at our salesman's
come up and approached us and then
finally we might be looking around the
showroom and saying hey what kind of
showroom is this what are you guys
showing to me we can do car type we see
that it comes up these cares typo there
these cars are and then it looks at the
car type and says manual so you're in
the manual car showroom now this is all
great you have your class car let me go
ahead and just get rid of some of this
stuff take it back a notch clean it up
take out keep our bmw and four down
there and so with our class car we now
have under there an init we'll keep the
init where we put in the year and the
speed and we set that i've taken out my
static method but i do want to add in
let's go back and put the get speed back
in itself get speed and we'll just print
like we had before maximum speed and
because we put it in as a for the
instance we'll do self dot speed that's
how we reference it there so right now
we have our basic class car that looks
pretty good but what if we were talking
about remember we had like these models
are all standard these models are all
whatever what if i want to have a class
sedan so we're looking at just sedans
but i wanted to have all the features of
the car i don't want to have to do a
economy a sedan a four-wheel drive i
don't want to redo all the work i do in
car because the get speed is going to be
the same the year and everything else is
going to be the same what i can do is we
can do an inheritance and that means
when i do a class sedan of car this
inherit everything from car so
everything i have above in car is
inherited so any instance i create of
sedan uses all the values in car and we
can do we can change some things on here
but let me just show you how this works
to begin with instead of doing i can do
this part right here let me just do uh
bmw dot get speed so i still have my car
class so if i run this you will see
indent error because i forgot i created
the this here let's go pass is just a
fancy way of putting a placeholder here
saying the code is here but don't do
anything so i processed maximum speed is
155. and what happens instead of a car
we do a sedan and we run this i still
get maximum speed is 155. well sedan
doesn't have that in there but sedan
inherited everything from car so when we
look at this i have maximum speed equals
self.speed and i admit the
initialization is the same self.year
self.speed on there now we can also do
something like this with sedan i can
take to copy all this over generally you
don't just do a pass here the very least
you need your init file in this and so
here's my initialization and so with
sedan we're going to do something like
this i'm going to go super.net
year comma speed and what i'm telling it
is it comes in and says okay i'm
initializing a sedan this is my
initialization code but we're going to
go to the class that this inherited from
which is our car and we're going to do
the init there this basically comes up
here and says okay this is our init this
is how we're going to initialize this
but in addition to that what i want to
do is i also want to do something like
this print this is a sedan and so now
when i run this our bmw initializes as a
sedan it does the super so it uses all
of the init code underneath our class
car and then in addition to that is
whatever i wanted to do in this case i
want to just print this is a sedan so
you can see it prints this is a sedan
and then when i run git speed it still
utilizes that from the original class so
now i also have the speed and the
initialization all under my original
class car i'm not recreating it and
retyping it copying it down there and
just like we have defs appear under
class we might have certain definitions
which are very specific to the sedan so
maybe we have open trunk so we'll put
that in there there's our definition for
open trunk and all it does is print open
trunk and so i can do bmw dot open trunk
and if i run this my bmw now can open
the trunk so now it has additional
functionality that cars doesn't we can
see this if i do four dot open trunk and
if you guessed it it'd give us a error
you're correct car doesn't have an open
trunk i'm sorry it's an error this ford
maybe it's a ford truck doesn't have a
trunk so it can't open it so this is
only if it's a sedan does it have open
trunk underneath of it and this just
adding all that new definitions is our
polymorphism we can polymorph our class
to do things the original class couldn't
do and we can go ahead we could take
this oh let's let's change this up a
little bit here we'll initialize this
with name and then self dot name equals
name and instead of having setting the
speeds here we'll just give we'll just
say that this particular individual car
maximum speed of 150 forget speed and
we'll do the same thing down here we'll
have our instead of a sedan let's do
this let's just take this completely out
of here we'll take our sedan and the
sedan will have a speed of 150. but
instead of us yeah sedan that works
we'll just do sedan and then maybe we'll
also have another one that is an suv and
so our suv class they all have a maximum
speed of 120 name this suv and so now
that we have these two classes they're
both inheriting from cars so when we
send something to them we're going to
send name self.name and then we have def
getspeed which is going to return 150
class suv maximum speed is 120. so we're
storing the name underneath the each
instance of it and then we're also going
to get a different speed each time let's
do a list we'll do a car list here's our
list of cars there's our brackets for
our list and then i'm going to do
something kind of fun here here's a
sedan now the sedan is the class so
that's an object so i can make a list of
that object and in that particular
object we're going to give it a name and
the name of this one is going to be it's
a camry very common car out there and
then i'm going to create a second object
it's going to be an suv class now
remember we also did variables as
definitions certainly you can put
anything that's an object into a
variable so these are a list of classes
on here with their calls in the suv
we're going to do i guess scorpio i'm
not too familiar with the scorpio car
but i guess it's one of the common suvs
in certain areas so now i have a list of
two classes and these classes are both
initialized the first one with camry and
with scorpio and from before we can do
four car and car list so we're going to
do each car and then we're just going to
do something simple like print in this
case car dot name and kind of a fun one
we'll add the plus sign in and the
brackets and the colon and
just a second to put this together comma
end
equals double brackets this is basically
we're telling it don't print a new line
i want to print the car followed by car
dot accelerate let's remember we had
actually we did to get speed so we'll do
we'll stick with get speed control copy
get speed put in our double brackets i'm
just going to add a space up here and
here oops actually goes at the beginning
so if i run this it should go all the
way through this list here's our for
loop remember this how we talked about
iterating through a list of objects
there's our car list and as we go
through we see scorpio we have our camry
camry is maximum speed 150 scorpio
maximum speed 120. so we put together a
nice set of polymorphism of classes we
polymorphed our our car class into a
sedan and into an suv so they each have
these print out a very different thing
or have a very different kit speed
functionality but they both inherit the
initial def from car we're going to take
on seven parts or seven code challenges
that you can do to take all the basics
we've covered so far in python and see
how to apply them and we'll start with
part one part one we want to go ahead
and see if we can print the number of
occurrences of each character in a
string and this would be a good time to
pause the video so you can actually try
to solve it on your own before we go
ahead and give you the solution we came
up with now remember there's always
multiple solutions to any of these
challenges so if you come up with a
different one that's great you know it
just means you're thinking on there the
first thing we want to do is we want to
go ahead and get an input so we want to
go ahead and pull up an input for our
word that we're going to type in and
then we're looking for the number of
characters in a string so we need some
way to track it and we have what we call
a dictionary now if you remember we
briefly touched upon the dictionary a
dictionary is denoted with two brackets
and it comes in the form of a key so
you'll have your key code and then that
key code is set to a value so the value
can change the key code cannot and if we
had brackets around this could initiate
it if you already know your initial keys
and values with something that looks
like this and we can also here's our d
assign them as we go and so we'd have
our key
and then this would equal our value and
what's nice about these two setups is
that we have a key code which could
represent our characters and then we
have the value which is going to
represent the count hopefully you
remember map reduce we're thinking map
and reduce this is such a common
question that comes up in map and reduce
so we're going to map all our characters
out and then count them and reduce that
to in a huge map reduce program you
would actually do each document had to
have a summation and then that would be
sent and brought together and then
reduced to just a single representation
of it so we're doing kind of the end
part where we're just reducing this word
so here we have our dictionary and then
we want to go ahead and do a 4-i loop
for i and s so our input is s and this
will iterate over each character in the
string and the next thing we want to
know is do we already have d in our
dictionary in this case we're looking at
each of our eyes so if i and d so if
it's already in there then we can simply
do this we can simply do d of i
and then you can do the plus equals and
then of course we're just adding 1 to x
or incrementing it by 1. now if it
doesn't exist in the dictionary and you
try to do that you'll get an error it'll
say no key value there so now we have to
do a thing where if i is not in d we do
simply d of i and we initialize it with
one keep it simple and then finally
we've got all our different things we
can just print d and if i run this let's
go ahead and take that and run it comes
up says enter a string and we'll do
hello i'll hit enter and you'll see i
have h capital h equals one lowercase e
equals one l equals two there's two l's
and o equals one you can also uh if
you're trying to look at it a little bit
clear you could do for key and d we
could do something like this print d
of key and you gotta remember it doesn't
actually print the key unless you tell
it to so here's the key in the d of key
so i can also do it this way see if we
can pick another a better word on here
you can actually do a full phrase in
here so uh welcome to python and hit
enter and you'll see that we have w1 e
has two l has one c one o three m1
there's two spaces
t is two p is one y is one h and so on
so this is a very simple set of loops
but it covers a lot of interesting key
points that you'll use throughout any
kind of big data or map and reduce
program so let's move to part two or
challenge two let me just clear my
palette so we have a nice palette and
what we're going to do for part two is
we're going to insert an element at the
k position of a list and again you know
pause it if you need to let's go ahead
and create our list and in this case
we're going to do just a standard list
we'll do some mixed elements we'll have
like 23. it looks like they sent me an
example of the list let me just grab
that so let's do 23 hey oh 89 python so
we have a nice list there with one two
three four five objects or zero through
four if you're thinking indexing and
let's go ahead and do this we'll print
let's just print the original list
comma list and then we need our input n
equals input and i guess we need to put
where we're going to enter it at so it
says input and let's do enter on index
between they have let's see we can just
a couple different ways but let's say we
do
0 which would put it at the beginning
and and then at the end how would you
get to know the end well we could do
this plus string of length uh in this
case length of list and remember we
don't want to type in the actual i guess
they could type in the actual n so it
could be 0 or it could be the very end
of the list so this n should give us a
nice input and then let's have an object
or we'll just call it k
actually let's put this above sometimes
it's nice to put these in a different
order k equals input let's go ahead and
have it enter an element and so this
will automatically be a string that we
enter here i'm going to go ahead and
just add a space there so it stays on
the same line if you have a larger
screen this might look better if it goes
down a line but in this case i want to
go ahead and just keep that in the same
line and we'll do this on here i'll do
plus
and add a space and this will be our
element in and k for the actual integer
and we want to make sure this stays as
an integer so let's go ahead and take
this whole thing and add integer at the
beginning it's for our index
integer at the end so now we have our
input we're going to add an element in
this case it's going to always be a
string unless we want to try to convert
it and then we're going to enter in
where it's going to go and so how do we
get there how do we put that in that
list
and so there is actually a number of
ways you can actually do an insert but
let's say we don't have the list insert
command make a little hard on us let's
go ahead and do this let's go ahead and
do a list append and we're going to
append in this case k that's the entity
we entered in here so if we pretend not
to do the list insert and we have the
append we can append our value on to the
end of our list and what we're going to
do and again there's like so many
different solutions for this i mean if i
was just doing an insert into my list i
would just do an insert but let's say
sometimes you have to do
other than finding out the spot on there
you might be comparing the values or
doing something else going on so we can
do is we can go for i and range
zero comma length of list so we're going
to create an integer that comes in here
and just starts at the zero index so i
for index and just pages through all of
our objects in the list and we want to
know is if i is greater than and we had
our k value now if you did like i did up
here 0 you could also do k value equals
1. so this gets a little tricky on your
input if you're talking about your in
client do they know to start 0 as play 0
or do they start with place 1. so that
might change your coding and how you put
this together those are things you'd
want to think about and we're going to
do temp equals list of i so we go ahead
and we look at our list and we say okay
i'm going to pull this object off i'll
create a temp here list of i
equals n and we're going to swap in our
n value and then we'll do n equals temp
so let's take a look at this i have if i
is greater than k and since we're
starting with 0 we're going to do i is
greater than or equal to k that's just
because we're starting with a 0 instead
of 1. and we take we go ahead and create
a temp variable that goes to that
pointer list of i then equals n that's
our last element in this case it's the
one we entered and then we set n equal
to temp so we take this and we take
whatever's in that position we put it in
temp and then we just go all the way
through and what happens is it'll just
keep replacing that value all the way to
the end and let's go ahead and see what
that looks like before we do this i
guess we have to print out an answer so
we'll come down here we'll go print and
our updated list
comma and this is just list let's go
ahead and run this and we'll go down
here and let's enter in hello and i
always like to do the extremes we have
zero and five so let's go into zero and
enter and we have our list which is
original 23 all the way to python and
now it says hello and puts it right at
the beginning if you're going to do that
you should also test out the end of the
list so what happens if i put in five
and it comes up and you see it puts
hello at the end what happens if we put
in four double check here we go four and
it comes up on place number four and
i'll do one more test on this just
because i really don't like things going
out the door unless i know they work and
we'll put in one and you'll see here 0 1
2 3 and so on and there's our hello and
you can see here we had a nice setup on
that we have our input and we just go
through it's really important to note
that we're iterating through each value
and we're seeing if something important
is going to need to change that value
this could be almost anything this could
be that you need to alter not only
insert the value but maybe increment
everything past it with plus one or
something there's all kinds of things
that can come up little weird logic that
you wouldn't think of until you start
messing with it challenger part three
check if the substring is present in a
string without using the find method i
remember back in the 90s this was
central to all of your programming was
to do all these little things now of
course they have fine built into the
functionality so string we need to have
our input we're going to input a string
and we're going to input a substring and
we'll call them st for string and sub
for substring and i'm going to jump
ahead a little bit here and then come
back because we want to look at
something let's do count equals 0 and
then we're going to do our loop for i in
range 0 we want to start with position 0
and then we want to go to
what that's where the question comes in
well we could do the length of the
string now there's a problem with this
and that is that the substring might be
5 letters long so if i go to the length
of the string i'm actually comparing the
substring to something that isn't even
there so i'm going past the end of the
string that's not really worth doing so
how do we figure out that number well we
can do l equals length of our substring
so now we have a value for how long the
substring is and we simply take the zero
to length of string minus l and then we
want to add one on there so remember
that this length it goes exactly to that
length without including it so we have
to add the plus one in there to include
the very end of that so 0 to the length
of the string so the next question is
how do we know we have it well if our
substring equals string and we want to
start from position i and we want to go
to i
plus l the length of the substring so if
they're equal we'll print count plus
equals one our increment of one and
we'll do
print
sub string here's our placeholder s for
a string found at position and then
here's our placeholder for a number or d
in this case and we'll go ahead and give
it just a space off of here oh that's
fine we don't need a space on that and
then we have our amber sign a percent
sign and our tuple so here's our tuple
we want sub comma i uh so that'll put
that right in there this will tell us
that it's in there each time it finds a
substring we're counting it then we
print it out that is part of it a little
redundant because you'll just print out
the same thing over and over again and
then we can do if count
equals
zero we can print substring not found
and of course an else statement else
print and we'll do substring
substring here's our place marker again
s
found
another placeholder d
times and then we can if you're into
your placeholders of course you have to
do your tuple at the end and we have our
sub comma in this case count so let's
see what that looks like when it runs
before we do that let's just walk
through it so let's take a walk through
what we just did so we have for i equals
range we had to kind of uh fill a little
bit with the length to make sure we got
all the way to the end but we didn't go
past it for finding our sub in the range
of the string simple if statement says
hey it's here count plus equals one
let's go ahead and print our substring
found this will be very repetitive so i
don't even know wouldn't normally put
this in here just to keep printing it
and then it says if count equals zero we
found none print substring not found and
else uh substring s found d times with
our count so let's go ahead and run this
and here it goes uh enter our string
uh welcome to
simply learn i'm gonna hit enter and
we're gonna look for the let's go two
and it gave me an error so what happened
here and i of course get an error
hopefully you caught this error when i
was putting it together this should be a
colon not a comma this is a straight
list so that's why you got to remember
what ray you're working in and it does
happen and we'll go ahead and run this
again and we'll do welcome to
simply learn type in our 2 and it comes
up and says substring 2 found 1 times
substring found at position 8. so now we
know a position it's at and we also have
how many times it was found and since i
was just talking about numpty arrays
let's do challenger part four find the
index for the nth repetition of a number
in a numpy array so let's go ahead and
import our numpy as np you'll see that
very standard and i went ahead and
created an array or team in the back did
so we are going to create our variable
ar set to a numpy array and it's just
one two four one twenty three one two
three four so it's kind of a random set
of numbers on here and let's see how we
can build this and at this point you
should be trying to think about how to
do it yourself and let's go ahead and
i'll just paste this in here we're going
to print the original array just so you
can double check it in our output and
we're going to do our input num equals
an integer and then give a value for the
number for your input so we'll have our
num we're going to look for and let's do
this if num in r so the first thing we
want to know is even is in there there's
always a chance you might not even have
that number in there initiating or doing
initial case so if we're looking for
kind of the base case of do we want to
even do anything if it's not in there so
if number in ar first thing you want to
do is check otherwise it's not worth
processing and then let's do this so we
want to ask the question what is the
index for the nth repetition so we got
to find out what repetition the user
wants and we'll go ahead and create
another input in give a value for
n which is our repetition or repeat so
give a value for n or the repeat on here
now at this point there's so many
different ways to solve this we could
iterate through but we're going to
create and you'll hear the term mask let
me just type that out for you where
you're masking something masking means
that we create a series of values in
this case we're going to create a bunch
of ones we're going to say it equals np
so here's our numpy array where our
input array equals our number so this is
going to return a numpy array of either
ones or zeros then we can actually test
it and see what's in there now there's
other ways we could just iterate through
the numpy array usually when you're
working with numpy arrays you try not to
iterate across them the whole purpose of
the numpy array is to let it leverage
the back end code so you're not wasting
as much resources and you know what
let's go ahead and print one out just so
you can see what that looks like what
this masking does so np where r equals
number let's go ahead and run that and
here's our setup let's do enter in the
number one and value for in repeat uh it
doesn't really matter because we're not
doing anything with that yet we'll put
in three and if you look at the output
of this mask we've created it's set up
and returns an array and the array is 0
3 5 9 15 18. it returns all the
positions of our number in the array so
here's np where r equals number and then
we just called it 1. if you print one
out you can see we just get a nice list
of indexes and this is really useful to
us let's go back in here and then we can
very simply on the indexes do if we have
our
n and we'll do less than or equal to the
length of our one and remember this is a
tuple coming in this array so we have
the first part is the actual indexes and
the second part is our d type so we
really want to do the one of zero and
this is important if you haven't worked
with numpy arrays or even if you work
with them a lot sometimes you just do a
quick printout to find out what it is
you're looking at so you can remember
the format on there and we'll do this if
it's less than or equal to the length of
one or zero then we can simply print
one of our zero position and then on
here we want to do since that's also
itself is array we want to do the n
minus one remember we start with zero so
if we want to find out in the how many
is in there or you know what the
position it is we're counting one two
three but the array is 0 1 2. so we have
to put the n minus 1 in there and of
course if we don't find it we'll do an
else statement and we'll print there
aren't and then we'll go ahead and put
down a placeholder just we can keep
track of it currencies of one just keep
it simple this time and then finally
we'll go back here and he had our
original if number in the r we course
have an else print that is not in there
boom and let's go ahead and run that and
we have our list down here let me move
this thing back up so we can see what
the run looks like we'll look for this
to look for a one and we want it to
repeat emma fourth and it returns it in
position nine there we go and if we went
up here and entered in let's enter in
just a random number i don't see the
number 33 so we'll put 33 in there 33
not in the array so it doesn't even go
through because we put that initial test
right at the beginning that says hey if
it's not in here don't even bother and
then we went through and counted them
now you probably found your own solution
very central to our solution was the
where statement where it's going to map
out the indexes of this occurrence where
r equals number and this is part of
masking there's all kinds of ways to
mask your data usually you mask the
whole array across something when you
talk about masking in this case we're
just returning a simple array where it
lists the indexes let's go ahead and
clean our screen here for
part five generate a dictionary that
contains pairs such as i comma i times i
where i integer is between one and an
entered value sometimes i'll break these
up if i'm for readability so we'll do
that there we go so we're going to
generate a dictionary that's the first
thing we need to do and we need a value
entered so let's go ahead and do both of
those and there's a couple ways to
generate a dictionary earlier we did the
two squiggly brackets you can also just
do d equals dictionary if i run this
you'll see that it works and that's for
a number let me go ahead and enter in
four and processes i could have easily
just have also done this with a double
brackets that's the same thing so if you
see something dictionary you could also
these are equivalent statements d equals
brackets and d equals dictionary or the
dictionary object and we'll do uh four i
and range one
in plus one so there's a number we
entered and in our dictionary we're
gonna do d of i there's our key equals
and our value i
times i and you could have also done
since this is just squaring it we could
have also done squared that's the same
thing as i times i i squared but we'll
go ahead and do i times i and then we'll
simply because you want to see what your
end is is print d and let's go ahead and
run this and we'll shift this up just a
little bit it says enter a number we'll
enter 3 and if i run that or if i hit
enter on there i get 1 1 so one squared
is one two squared is four three squared
is nine and you could go on as far as
you wanted on there i could enter in a
significantly larger number but it goes
up to whatever my range is on that this
is again an example of dictionary how to
build a dictionary in simple ways on
there all right let's go ahead and clear
our screen for part six
write a program which takes two digits x
y as input and generates a matrix the
element value in the ith row and the jth
column of the array should be i times j
there's a lot of ways to do this we're
going to do this as a
list of lists my first thought though
would be to put this in numpy because
numpy can do this very there's a lot of
automated ways to do this in numpy but
let's go ahead and look at the back end
how would you do this into a regular
list so before we start solving this
problem how do we get our data we have
two inputs what if i wanted to have just
one input where i have you enter x comma
y what would that look like take out the
space there because that could cause an
issue well there's a couple ways to do
this one is if we want to generate an x
y this number is going to return a tuple
for whatever i do we could do something
like this so on here we're entering a
string with two integers how do we
convert those well we can do integer x
for x in string dot split this is a
really kind of a fun shorthand for
python for iterating through our setup
so what we got here is we're going to
first of all split our string so here's
our string it comes in with
2 comma 3 and then we take and we split
it by the comma and for each entity in
that split we want to return the integer
of that entity in this case we've
labeled it x and so this should go
through and do x y and it should return
an x integer and a y integer and let's
just see what that looks like let me
just go ahead and print x comma y and
let's go ahead and run that and here our
x y is we go three comma two hit enter
and it enters three comma two now if
you're putting out a full package what
happens if you have somebody who's
overzealous and does something like this
3 45 3 enter we're going to get a and
unpack too many values so this returned
this huge list of
numbers i typed in and gave me an error
so you got to remember that when you're
doing these different inputs you might
sort it out and just look for the first
two of them there's all kinds of
different ways to do this so now we have
our xy if you went ahead and just did
the enter x and enter y that's okay and
we want to generate a list so our list
that we're going to put together is
going to be and again we're doing some
nested stuff here which is a lot of fun
we're going to create a 2 by 2 matrix
and so we're going to have 4 0 for
column and range y and for row and range
x so what we're doing here is this is
going to put a 0 in each of these in
here and then this is simply column is r
for column column is nothing more than a
placeholder i could have done for c in
range y same thing with row that's
because it has to have a value that
shows up here and we're just going to
fill everything with 0. and let's go
ahead and print this print
list we run this and you'll see here's
our inner x y we'll do 3 comma three and
we end up with zero zero zero zero zero
zero zero zero zero here's our two
iterations done the pythonian way it's
going to return you have the square
brackets on the end so it's returning an
array and for the first one we're going
to put 0
for column in range of y and then we're
going to repeat that again for row and
range of x instead of 0 we can simply do
this i can do column times row and if we
run this we'll see here's our x y
let's do 3 comma 3 again that way it's
not too big on there and we end up with
0 0 0 0 1 2 0 2 4. and we might get a
little fancy in this and do oh you know
what let's do it this way import numpy
as np and then maybe we'll do numpy
array equals np.array
of and then we'll enter in our list that
we created and then let's print
in pa remember that when i see here
matrix i automatically go right in for
the numpy array so we'll enter our three
comma three and you can see here that
numpy is designed for doing matrixes and
so we have zero times zero zero times
one zero times two one times zero one
times one one times two and so on so we
create a nice little matrix of i to j
and then we put it into numpy just
because we can and numpy has such a
nicer format on there so let's go ahead
and clear our palette let's move on to
part
seven and in part seven we're going to
find the hcf of a two numbers using
recursion and hcf if you don't know what
hcf is its highest common factor or
denominator of two numbers using
recursion um i couldn't remember it i
had to look that up so let's do a
definition we'll create our little
function hcf and what comes into there
is going to be x and y and what i want
to know is we want the highest one so
we'll do if first of all y
is not equal to zero if it's equal to
zero you you don't want to divide it
anything because it'll give you an error
anything divided by 0. and let's take
that and we're going to just return
hcf of y comma x and here's a remainder
of y so hcfy of x a remainder of y so
we're looking for this is just the
remainder so it's going to return the
remainder on here on this else
we want to return x and so we would need
our input on this before we go any
further so let's grab a input and we'll
do the same kind of input we did before
we're entering x and y enter two
positive integers and this is just from
a previous example so we'll just go
ahead and grab the integer x for x in in
this case it's not string keep it the
string on there s t and have our two
integers here from before keep it simple
and then let's just go ahead and combine
it all into one line pythonian way if
you can put it into one easy to read
line then you should do so so we're
going to print hcff of placeholder d and
placeholder d is also is placeholder d
and this is our x our y and then we're
going to just print out the return value
of our hcf of xy now let's go ahead and
run this we're going to enter in two
positive numbers let's go 12 and 18. and
so the hcf of 12 and 18 is six that
would be our most common denominator
let's go ahead and clear out part seven
and then uh bonus
we are going to throw in a part eight
quick sort so we have bonus round part
eight quick sort and we're going to
positive list of
integers so we're going to do a quick
sort on positive list of integers on
here there's like so many different ways
to do different sortings on this one of
the ways to do it is to look at a list
and then partition that list and then
you go through that partition and you
sort it and then you sort a smaller list
a small list and so on and so on so
that's what we're going to do on this
one before we start though we do need to
go ahead and grab our
data and set that up and so you can do
it a number of different ways we can do
comma separated we're going to switch it
up a little bit on this one because it's
just fun to try different things and
we're going to do enter in n number of
objects in the list we're going to enter
each of those values into our array and
our array we're just going to input an
integer of them print the original list
this should be pretty familiar because
we've done so many inputs in this lesson
in the last lesson all we're doing on
this one is we're just appending the
input here and how many inputs and still
go down the list and if we go ahead and
just run this first piece of code real
quick number of objects in the input
we'll do three values of the objects
we'll do three
two five and you can see here's our
original series three two five pretty
basic and straightforward and because uh
for me space is a commodity as far as
our output and the screen i have for
your catching you and what you're
reading there we'll just put it on one
line we'll say original list so the
first thing we want to do is if we're
going to do partitions let's create a
module for partitioning out our data and
so we'll start with a simple definition
procedure and we'll call it uh partition
and we want to take our list that it's
sent we want a low value a high value
and what we're going to do with this is
we're going to create
i
equals low minus 1. so remember this is
an index and we actually started with
zero so now we're actually one less than
the index if we're initiating this with
zero on one end and the maximum on the
high end and we'll call it pivot and the
pivot is going to be a value we'll set
that list equal to our list of our high
index so remember high and lower indexes
i is an index pivot is a value that's
the actual value in this position of
whatever we send it so we're going to
send it two pointers low and high and
we're going to send it the list and when
we initiate this we usually will set it
up as a first entity which is index of 0
for low and then for a high we'll have
the highest index on there then we need
to go ahead and do for j in range low
comma high so we're going to go through
all the different values in there and if
list
of j is less than or equal to pivot then
i equals i plus one but we like to do it
the python way so plus equals one now
remember we subtracted one up here so
this is one less than whatever index we
sent it which if we start with zero
would be minus one and this brings it
back up to zero so this is why we put
this in here at the top part i'm
actually going to stop here just for a
second because sorting is one of the
most basic things but it's very
confusing as to why the sorting is so
difficult and one of the reasons it's so
difficult is because if i have the
numbers three two one there's so many
different ways to sort this one i could
take and look at these two numbers and
if this value is higher than this one i
could swap them which would then give me
2 comma 3 comma 1 and then i can look at
these two numbers and if this is bigger
then i can do swap them and then i get 2
comma 1 comma three and then i gotta
start over because now the two and the
one aren't in order and so you can see
with the lengthy list whatever i do
starts running into factorials n
factorial runs and there's no real easy
way around this because if i put a
reverse list 321 it's going to maximize
how many runs it takes and so finding
different ways to sort the data
depending on what you're doing can be
really confusing so understanding just
what's going on with this particular
sort we're doing helps to start
understanding where this problem occurs
and certainly there's tools out there to
sort it for you which are already
maximized sometimes you have to sort on
values that aren't you know the value
you're sorting on might be different it
might be instead of sorting on j it
might be the remainder of j divided by
something or it might be the percentage
of j over another column so being able
to sort these things is important and
knowing how this works the logic behind
it is more important than the actual
coding at this point so we get in here
we go i equals i plus one so remember
that i put this case we did it somehow
reverted there i plus equals one and
then we're going to do list of i comma
list
of j
equals list of j
comma list of i and this is just a cool
python way of swapping values you can
see here we have j i becomes i j so
we're literally we're swapping the
values up here as we go through this
partition on right here and this works
on our counting because we have i which
right off the bat is set to zero we have
high which is not the end value but one
less than the n value so our range of j
is going from zero to
not quite the last digit and our i is
going from we've added the plus one and
then it goes to the end here so we have
our list of i or list of j and we swap
them out depending on if list of j is
greater than pivot and we can also do
something like this here's our pivot and
we'll just take our pivot out up here so
here we have our list of high is going
to be our pivot number that we're
switching around and we're just
iterating it through and swapping values
and then finally we'll go ahead and run
this one more time list of i plus one of
list of high equals list of height comma
list of i plus one so one last swap at
the end now if you're looking at i
equals low minus one let's do this this
is kind of fun to do clean up our code a
little bit i'm incrementing it right
here why i don't know i can increment it
right afterwards and it has the same
result of taking the minus one off of
here and just adding it after i need it
and this then carries down to here where
i have i plus 1 while i'm adding it at
the end so i don't need to add it again
and we simplify it down to i equals low
following our eyes through there we have
list of i list of j listed j list of i
swapping here's our increment and then
our final swap at the end and what we
want to go ahead and do is we just want
to return
i
plus 1. and so if we're going to have
our partition set up this way we're
returning the i plus 1 or in this case
just i we want to return i carried it
down forgot to carry it down there we've
taken our list we've swapped it around
because we're passing the list we're
passing the actual list not just a
pointer to it and then we're going to
return the eye so we know what we did
and so if you remember down there when i
did that example the first time through
we swap it around and then it comes up
and says oh okay we've already swapped
the high value all the way up to the
right hand side then we have to start
over so we'll go ahead and call this
quick sort and the quick sort is going
to take the list a low and a high just
like we did for our partition and we
want to do that is if low is less than
high then we want to go ahead and
partition the index let me fix my tabs
there we go so pt is the value from the
partition that's coming back that's what
says i returned and so we would go ahead
and partition our list and we have our
low and high value going in there if
we're going to partition our list once
we get the pt back
we can go ahead and do a quick sort on
the same list low comma pt minus 1. so
it goes through the list it moves the
highest value to the end and then we
want to take that pt it returns and we
want to subtract one because we know
where the high point is so now we have a
shorter list to go through and we sort
it from the other end too we'll do a
quick sort and we'll do our list comma
pt
plus one comma high so we're coming out
from the other end so we're basically
sorting the list going both directions
on here so this is our sort on this one
we've now sorted our list so we need to
go ahead and call that and we can simply
call that let's see oh we can print out
the list
let's do this let's go print there's our
original list
sorted list and we'll put our little
placeholder or you know what we won't
put a placeholder there we'll just put a
comma in and of course it probably helps
to actually return the list so we'll go
up here and do uh return list that we've
nicely sorted on here and we'll come
down here to this part and do quick sort
and we have our list that we put in
we're going to start with the 0 for
initiating it and then we have our high
value which is simply the length of the
list because that points to it's
actually linked to the list minus one
that's going to point to the last index
and then real quick before i run this
let's do some quick cleanup here the
original list and then we want to create
a second list which equals the original
and then we're going to print our sorted
list and we're going to send it this
information for our quick sort so let's
go and see what that looks like let's go
ahead and run this and we're going to
enter our number of values we'll just do
3 and we're going to enter in 3 2 1.
let's open this up so we can see what's
going on down here so here's our
original list three two one and you can
see it's nicely sorted one two three and
if i was testing this out i would enter
in one two three to see what happened i
would enter in two three one just some
quick changes to make sure it's sorting
correctly in fact let's go ahead and do
that real quick let's go ahead and enter
another list we'll do it four and i'll
do one two three four one two three four
sorts out as one two three four and i
actually know from doing these so many
times that that's more than enough on
these but just in case let's go two one
three four and one two three four there
we go quick sort for our list
certainly the questions we're going to
ask in here are very general with a few
specifics towards data science since
that's the main direction that python's
going in and you'd want to expand your
questions for your interview depending
on the domain that you're using the
python in specifically let's dive in and
get started with some python interview
questions number one what is the
difference between shallow copy and deep
copy and you can see with shallow copy
we have object one which has child one
child two child three and so on and
object two which has child one child two
child three a deep copy creates a
different object and populates it with
the child objects of the original object
therefore changes in the original object
is not reflected in the copy copy dot
deep copy creates a deep copy shallow
copy creates a different object and
populates it with the references of the
child objects within the original object
therefore changes in the original object
is reflected in the copy copy.copy
creates a shallow copy and you can look
at this if we make a change to child one
it's only a pointer so if you make it in
object one and change to child one and
object one it will also make that change
in object two number two how is
multi-threading achieved in python oh
this is a good one with multi-processing
and multi-threading this question is
actually asking you do you know the
difference between multi-processing and
multi-threading and how multi-threading
works multi-threading usually implies
that multiple threads are executed
concurrently the python global
interpreter lock doesn't allow more than
one thread to hold the python
interpreter at that particular point of
time so multi-threading in python is
achieved through context switching it's
very different than multi-processing
which actually opens up multiple
processes across multiple threads so
multi-threading discuss the django
architecture so the django architecture
and the first thing to know is that the
django is a web service way to build
your web pages basically and so we look
at the architecture you can see here we
have a nice model drawn out where the
user initiates the django which
initiates the url which indicates the
view what they're going to view and you
have your model and your template so the
model of data whatever data model you're
pulling goes into the template and then
goes back up the pipeline to the user
and the important thing to note is
there's a template the front end of the
web page this is what they're going to
see there's a model the back end where
the data is stored so you can keep the
template and the looks and everything
looks the same but you can swap out the
underlying formation that goes into that
template then you have your view which
interacts with the model and template
and maps it to the url and then the
django serves the page to the user so
your django grabs it and says okay thank
you for the url and here you go user
what advantage does numpy array have
over a nested list
so numpy's a module you import almost
always see numpy import numpy as np
numpy is written in c such that all its
complexities are backed into a simple to
use module lists on the other hand are
dynamically typed therefore python must
check the data type of each element
every time it uses it this makes number
arrays much faster than lists i would
also add in that numpy has a lot of
additional functionality that you don't
have in lists there's a lot of things
you can automate in the numpy quick flip
over to our jupiter notebook any ide
will work if you're going to do a set of
interview questions taking a quick look
at code is always important we have our
import numpy as np we'll go and import
time here's our list list sub for iron
range of 100 and what we're doing is
we're going to time it so we're going to
create a list then we're going to create
a numpy zeros array and you can see here
look how quick you can create this numpy
zeros array here we are appending one
zero at a time for a regular python list
and here we are with numpy they're all
zeros and they're all of type integer i
believe it's either float or integer on
this i'd have to actually do a type on
it and then so if we take in and we
create a tl1 time equals time and then
we do for i in range of 100 for j and
range of 100 l of i j equals l of i j
plus 5. so we're just doing a simple
calculation on our array and sub arrays
this is an array of rays and we'll do
the same thing with tl2 tl2 time dot
time tl1 so here we have our final time
on that and then we'll do this with an
array array op and this is what i really
love a equals a plus 10 and then you can
just print it right out so you can see
right here with a numpy array we're
doing the same thing if i run this our
time is significantly different here we
have 0.09 and 0.003
so you can see that the time drops
significantly when you're running this
on a numpy array versus a list array
also important to note these times
aren't going to be they'll change each
time i run it depending on what i have
running in the background so there we go
number five what is pickling and
unpickling amazes me how many times i
pickle and unpickle something converting
a python object hierarchy to a bite
stream is called pickling pickling is
also referred to as serialization
unpickling converting a byte stream to a
python object hierarchy is also called
unpickling unpickling is also referred
to as
deserialization so if you just created a
neural network model you can now save
that model to your hard drive pickle it
and then you can unpickle it to bring it
back into another software program or to
use at a later time how is memory
managed in python number six python has
a private heap space where it stores all
the objects the python memory manager
manages various aspects of this heap
like sharing caching segmentation and
allocation the user has no control over
the heap only the python interpreter has
the access you have a nice little
diagram here here's your program there's
your interpreter we have our heap memory
management on the garbage collector
going off of there number seven are
arguments in python pass by value or by
reference arguments are passed in python
by reference this means that any change
made within a function is reflected on
the original object so you can see here
def function of l l of 0 equals 3 l
equals 1 2 3 4 function l print l and
you're going to get 3 2 3 4 because
we've passed l in there so it's a
pointer here we have def function l l
equals 3 2 3 4 l equals 1 2 3 4 function
of l print l because in this function i
have assigned instead of operating on a
piece of l the list i've consigned a
whole new value to that list or l it
then at that point will create a new
object so if i make changes to the
object it's going to change it in the
outside the definition if i use a
variable and i cited a completely new
value like l equals 3 2 3 4 that will
not show up when you're outside the
function number 8 how would you generate
random numbers in python to generate
random numbers in python you must first
import the random module the random
function generates a random float value
between 0 and 1. the random range
function generates a random number
within a given range and you can see
here one is the lower end tens the upper
end and step two so it'd be one three
five and so on as far as the options in
the random generation number nine
what does the double forward slash
operator do in python the forward slash
operator performs division and returns
the quotient in float for example 5 over
2 returns 2.5 to do a double forward
slash operator on the other hand returns
the quotient an integer for example 5
double slash returns 2 5 divided by 2
and you drop the 0.5 number 10 what does
the is operator do the is operator
compares the id of the two objects and
you can see in here where list one
equals brackets round one two three list
one equals list two equals true and you
have the double equals in python of
course and you can do list one is list
two where list two equals one two three
is false list two is not the brackets
one two three it equals it but it's not
the brackets and if we do list three
equals list one then list one is list 3
equals true number 11 what is the
purpose of pass statement the pass
statement is used when there's a
syntactic but not an operational
requirement for example the program
below prints a string ignoring the
spaces and so here we have variable
equals simply learn we've added two
spaces in it for i and variable so it
goes through each eye if i equal space
do nothing else print i and then we'll
have the end equals bracket bracket and
they'll print out simply learn now of
course you would probably write this if
i does not equal blank space print but
this would be another way you could do
that if you need a placeholder for that
first logical set or that first area and
you can also do a function like this you
could do function
whatever your def function name brackets
colon pass so it goes into the function
and does nothing but it's a placeholder
number 12 how will you check all the
characters in a string are alphanumeric
python has an inbuilt method is all
number which returns true if all
characters in the string are
alphanumeric and so you can see here
abcd123
is all number output equals true and the
second line a b c d the at symbol one
two three the pound symbol is all nume
output equals false so really you just
want to know about is all new all
numerical alpha numerical number 12 how
will you check if all characters in a
string are alphanumeric
so here we go
if you know is all number which returns
that the characters in the string are
alphanumeric one can also use regex
instead and so we have boolean rematch
what's important about this is to note
your capital a dash to capital z a lower
cost to z 0 to 9 means that that array
includes all of those the way they have
it written out plus a dollar sign and
then we have what we're comparing it to
the string we're comparing to the
abcd123
and so we can do an re.match and if it
matches if all these things if all the
different entities in that array matches
the first one we get an output true and
if not an output false number 13 how
will you merge elements in a sequence
sequence there are three types of
sequences in python there's lists tuples
and strings python equals makes this
easy if we have a list one and list two
and list one is square brackets one
comma two comma three list two is four
five and six we can simply do list one
plus list two and our output is one two
three four five six if we have tuples
your tuple is the curve brackets
designates it and again just add them
together same thing with strings we have
simply learn s1 plus s2 equals simply
learn number 14 how will you remove all
leading white space in a string python
provides the inbuilt function l strip to
remove all leading access from a string
and you can see here spacebase base
python dot l strip leading strip python
and you can also do strip which release
leading and ending of course there's
also the ending set number 15 how will
you replace all occurrences of a stub
string with a new string the replace
function can be used with strings for
replacing a substring with a given
string syntax string.replace old comma
new comma count replace returns a new
string without modifying the original
string hey john how are you john
question mark replace john with capital
j-o-h-n one and then you can see right
here hey john how are you and since we
designated with the one just says we're
only going to replace one of these 16
what is the difference between dell and
remove brackets on lists del for delete
dell removes all elements of a list
within a given range syntax dell list
start to end remove remove brackets
removes the first occurrence of a
particular character syntax list remove
element and we see a nice example over
here if we delete the list one to three
it will delete the first in this case b
one two it doesn't do three remember
that one two so we'll delete b and c and
you end up with a d where if we do
remove b from the list and we have an
abbd it's only gonna remove the first b
number 17 how to display the contents of
text file in reverse order open the file
using the open function store the
contents of the file into a list reverse
the contents of the list run a for loop
to iterate through the list number 18
differential between append and extend
append adds an element to the end of the
list you can see right here we have a
list one two three four and we append
four we end up with an output one two
three four and extend adds an element
from an interval to the end of the list
and we have here list equals one two
three list dot extend four five six
output is one two three four five six so
if you wanna append an array to the end
of another array you wanna use the
extend number 19 what's the output of
the below code justify your answer this
is a great interview question because
these are the kind of things that come
up when you're proofing code def add to
list value and list so we have value in
and a list dent or list equals an empty
in this case an empty list list data pin
value return list list one equals add to
list one list two equals add to list one
two three empty bracket list three
equals add to list a and we want to
print them list 1 equals and you can see
the formatting we have our placeholder
list 1 list 2 and list 3. so when it
prints list 1 we get 1 comma a and what
you want to notice here is that list 1
and list 3 are equal why are they equal
well when we passed the information to
the add to list we passed value without
passing the list equals brackets without
passing a second value what this means
is that list as we have it if you don't
have a list it'll start off with empty
list which we append the one to the
second one list two we appended a value
to an empty list so it's only going to
be one two three it doesn't matter what
the list was before we've already
assigned an empty list and then list
three here's the tricky one we're adding
a to the list but because we didn't
designate the list list is a shared
value in other words it doesn't reset it
and we end up with list one equals list
three one comma a default this is
created only once during the function
and not during its call number 20 what
is the difference between a list and a
tuple lists are mutable while tuples are
immutable and you can see an example
down here where i have list equals one
two three square brackets denoted it's a
list list of two equals four and i
printed out i now have one two four if i
do the same thing with the tuple i get
an error because you can't change the
tuple one two three into one two four
you have to completely reassign tuple to
a new value what is doc string in python
doc strings are used in providing
documentation to various python modules
classes functions and methods and so you
can see here we have def for a function
add a b and this is a doc string we have
the triple brackets on there you can add
carriage return in that so that you can
go multiple lines and it says this
function adds two numbers and then sum a
b return sum and so we have down here
two different ways of accessing this
function output accessing docs string
method one this function adds two
numbers accessing docs string method two
help on function add in model main this
function adds two numbers and so you can
see the code down here has two very
different
in values the second one is basically a
help menu there's our help menu number
22
how do you use print without the new
line the solution to this depends on the
python version you are using in python
version 2 you can do print hi and then
you add a comma afterwards print how are
you and you have hi how are you in
version three print hi comma end equals
and it will add a space on the end there
you can put different characters in
there but you just want to put a space
to put a space on the end print how are
you and now we get hi how are you number
23 how do you use the split function in
python the split function splits a
string into a number of strings based on
a specific delimiter so we have string
split delimiter comma max the maximum
number of splits the character based on
which the string is to split by default
is space so here we have an example we
have a variable red blue green orange
and we want to split it by commas and we
only want to do the first two so if we
print the list now you'll find it has
red blue and only spread it split it the
first two times and it gets to the third
one and just groups them all together
green and orange if you leave the two
off you'll split the whole thing number
24 is python object oriented or
functional programming python follows
object oriented paradigm and you should
really know in depth what they mean by
object oriented paradigm if you're doing
any interview for scripting languages
python allows the creation of objects
and is manipulation through specific
methods it supports most of the features
of oops which as inheritance on a
polymorphism so you have an object and
you can inherit all the traits of that
object and then add new traits in or
alter some of those traits that's what
object oriented means python follows
functional programming paradigm
functions may be used as first class
object python supports lambda functions
which are characteristic of functional
paradigm so you can set a variable to a
function as opposed to setting it to an
object number 25 write a function
prototype that takes variable number of
arguments here we have def function name
list so we could have in this case
whatever the list is def function the
asterisk denotes so we're going to take
multiple arguments of a variable and
then we can do for i and var print i so
if you send function of one you'll end
up with a one function one two five six
you'll actually print those out one at a
time the first one just prints out a one
because it only sent one variable the
second one will print one another line
25 and the line six number 26 what is
asterix args and asterix korgs
args used in function prototype to
accept varying number of arguments it's
an iterable object def function arcs and
you can imagine it's just a basic list
so if i send add the numbers a comma b
or a comma b comma c it doesn't really
matter it'll have that number of objects
in it whatever i send to it and there's
other uses for it but that's very basic
korg's i can actually tell it what i
want to send so using a function
prototype and to accept varying number
of keyworded arguments it's in both our
interval objects so you can go through
them one at a time and the def function
chords you can now set like color equals
red units equal to so you'll see that
especially in machine learning there's a
lot of like they'll have inline equals
true that kind of thing number 27 in
python functions are first class objects
what do you understand from this this
means i could return a function could be
one from another function i could create
a function and treat it just like an
object i can assign it to a variable i
can pass them as arguments to other
functions number 28 what is the output
of print name underscore underscore name
and justify your answer the double
underscore name double underscore is a
special variable that holds the name of
the current module program execution
starts from main or a code with zero
indentation thus double underscore name
double underscore name has a value
double underscore main double underscore
in the above case if the file is
imported from another module then double
underscore name underscore double
underscore holds the name of this module
number 29 what is a numpy array and we
briefly touched numpy array compared to
a list early in processing speed now
let's go ahead and look at some of the
more specifics a numpy array is a grid
of values all of the same type so if
they're either all float all integer all
string and is indexed by a tuple of
non-negative integers the number of
dimensions is the rank of the array and
the shape of an array is a tuple of
integers giving the size of the ray
along each dimension number 30 what is
the difference between matrices and
arrays a matrix comes from linear
algebra and is a two-dimensional
representation of data it comes with a
powerful set of mathematical operations
that allow you to manipulate the data in
interesting ways now arrays an array is
a sequence of objects of similar data
type an array within another array forms
a matrix like we said here
two-dimensional so if you have an array
of three by four that would be a matrix
number 31 how to get indexes of n
maximum values in a numpy array of
course the first thing to do is to
import your numpy as np you don't
necessarily have to use mp but that is
the most standard use of numpy we create
our array equals an np.array of one two
three four five and then if we want to
get our indexes of n at maximum values
in a numpy array we can do one way to do
it is to take our array sort it then do
minus in colon that means we're going to
do once you've sorted it you can do
minus in n would equal then the number
of indices so it's not the actual letter
n colon and really this is about
understanding this notation that we can
sort it so it goes from lowest to
biggest and then we can get the top
values for n indexes and then we have
our final set of brackets with the minus
one on there number 32 how would you
obtain the resulting set from the train
set and the test set from below and
let's go ahead and look at the two
different variables we have train set
equals an array of one two three test
set equals a numpy of ray of arrays we
have zero one two one two three what's
important here is that one it's a numpy
so that leaves a out and then we're
stuck with three other options and i'm
gonna say the d is out none of these and
let's look at uh np dot concatenate
versus np dot v stack concatenate would
put one set after the other so you would
end up with probably give you an error
because one set is one two three and
then we're going to concatenate array
zero one two and one array one two three
the array of arrays onto the end of that
what we really want to do is stack and
by the ways you can actually switch
there's variables you can put into
concatenate obviously they can change
this so you could use the concatenate
with a lot of fudging around but really
we're looking for is v stack v stands
for vertical versus the h stack which is
horizontal and if we do a v stack we can
simply do train set comma test set and
stack them together and so we have c
resulting set equals np.v stack train
stack test set both option a and b would
do horizontal stacking but we would like
to have the vertical stacking option she
does this again you could add the axes
in and use the concatenate to stack it
the correct way number 33 how would you
import a decision tree classifier in sk
learn we have sklearn dot decision tree
import decision tree classifier from sk
learn ensemble import decision tree
classifier and we look at these they're
all import decision tree classifier that
actually last part happens to be correct
and it's really just a vocabulary
knowing where is the decision tree
classifier stored what module is that a
part of and it is of course part of the
sklearn.tree number c number 34 you have
uploaded the data set in csv format on
google spreadsheet and shared it
publicly how can you access this in
python what's important here is to know
that we can read stuff with pandas so we
don't show it here but you can there's
actually a number of ways to do this
what's important here is to know a
couple things one we have our link
generated from the google docs and
spreadsheets and then we can do a string
io dot string io request get link dot
content so there's our source and then
finally we know that pandas can read a
csv there's obviously many ways to read
a csv but data equals pd.read underscore
csv source number 35 what is the
difference between the two data series
given below below we have df name and df
location colon comma brackets around
asterisks around name comma where and
then we have df equals pd data frame aa
xxuu comma 21 165033
columns equal name and age so let's take
a look and see what they're looking at
we have just glancing at the questions
they want to know is it the original
data frame or is it the copy of the data
frame and you can see here that one is
view of the original data frame and two
is a copy of the original data frame two
is a view of the original data frame and
one is a copy of the original data frame
both are copies both are views and if
you're working with pandas you know that
unless you specifically in certain
things tell it to do it in line and a
lot of functions don't allow you that
you're always taking a slice and it is
always a copy so c both are copies of
the original data frame number 36 you
get the following error while trying to
read a file temp dot csv using pandas
which of the following could correct it
so here's our error trace back most
recent call last file input line 1 and
module unicode encode error ascii codex
can't encode character oh i hate it when
that one comes up and we have four
different entries we'll go ahead and
just pretend the d doesn't exist unless
we really can't fit it into one of the
other answers and the first one is pd
read csv has our file compression equals
gzip well gzip is just an unzipping and
you actually get a zip error on there
the second one is dialect equals string
again not an encoding or coding setup
and then we have encoding equals utf-8
well that would be the encoding error
switching it from the character code
there's utf-8 there is unicode that's
the most common two that goes between so
really this is about understanding the
difference between a utf-8 coding and a
unicode and the error that comes up
quite regularly with that number c
encoding should be utf-8 number 37 how
to set a line with any plot given below
so looking at this we have import map
plot library pi plot as plt and you
should know your way around this how to
do a plot in there
plt.plot1234 plot equals show and so
this is a little bit of a vocabulary
test the vocabulary is it width equals
three line width equals three lw equals
three or something else and the
vocabulary word that we're looking for
is lw equals three which stands for line
width in pi plot library pi plot number
38 how would you reset the index of a
data frame to a given list so this is a
vocabulary challenge and understanding
what reindexing is re-indexing as we
have the different values here we have
the first one which is reset the index
well we're not really resetting the
index re-index number b means we are
double checking our indexes to the
column and to the main index and so the
values match correctly where re-index
like now brings in a new index outside
of our data frame to a given list so
this is coming from external and thus
the vocabulary word like is our keyword
that is external and we have a data
friend to a given list number 39 how can
you copy objects in python the functions
used to copy objects in python we have
copy copy for shallow copying and copy
deep copying for deep copy number 40
what is the difference between range and
x range functions in python well this is
a good one we have matrixes and arrays
with a matrix the range returns a python
list object x range returns an x range
object and with arrays an x-ray returns
an x-range object x-range creates values
as you need them through yielding the
key here is that x-range returns the
values as you need them so it actually
processes it post like if you have for x
or for a variable in x range it is
processing them as you need them zero to
nine it doesn't create an array zero to
nine it just hands you zero then one two
three four one at a time number forty
one how can you check whether a pandas
data frame is empty or not the tribute
df.empty is used to check whether a
panda's data frame is empty or not and
so you can simply create a we have down
here import our pandas as pd we create
our pandas data frame equal to an empty
array and is df dot empty comes out as
true one of the catches you got to
remember with these vocabularies is with
empty along with some other pandas set
up whether you need the brackets or not
at the end number 42 write the code to
sort an array in numpy by the n minus 1
column this can be achieved using arg
sort function let's take an array x then
to sort the n minus 1 column the code
will be x to
x to colon in minus two dot args sort so
let's see what that code looks like we
import numpy as np we'll create our
array um our numpy array which is uh one
two three zero five two two three four
so we have three different entities with
three different columns in there and we
go x of x and so we take x of
all the rows first entity well in this
case it's actually the second one
because it's 0 1 2 dot arg sort so that
would be the second entity or minus two
would also be the same you could also do
instead of one you could also do minus
two there instead of the one arg sort
and then we get an output of the array
one two three zero five two two three
four number 43 how to create a series
from a list number array and dictionary
so we'll go ahead and input import our
numpy our pandas and have my list and
you can see here we have my list equals
list of a b c d e f g all the way
through so my list now makes a list of
that for
array we have np dot a range to 26 my
dictionary will create a dictionary with
a zip my list my arguments so just use
the numpy array we just created with my
array to go into
the dictionary and the solution is
simple with the
pd.series my list pd.series my array
pd.series my dictionary so it's all
about knowing the dot capital
s-e-r-i-e-s don't forget that
capitalization number 44 how to get the
items not common to both series a and
series b and you can see here we have
instead of series a and b we have series
one and two and we have one two three
four five four five six seven eight the
solution is we take a panda series we
have a series u equals a panda series np
union one dimension series one series
two so we can now make a union of them
we now have series one panda series with
an intersection and then we can remove
one from the other series u is series u
dot is in series one so if the union is
not in the intersection then you know
it's a unique value a little bit of
logic going on there playing with three
different terms to get the answer we
want 45 how to keep only the top two
most frequent values as it is and
replace everything else as other in a
series so again we're working with
pandas because we're talking series and
data frames that means we're working
with pandas so we're going to import
pandas as pd we'll go ahead and create
our panda series we're going to do that
by creating a numpy random random state
100 so 100 and the numpy one and then we
have our panda series you can see here
we're a random integer numpy random to a
random integer one comma five by 12. and
so the solution for this is we go ahead
and we've created a pd dot remember the
capital s series solution we're going to
print the top two frequencies and that
is our series dot value counts and then
we take series values count dot index of
up to two so we're going to take
everything up to two and then we'll do
the series is in so if it's not in the
first two then it's going to equal other
and this would be something you'd want
to write down on paper if you're if it
looks confusing take a moment pause the
video
write this down and see if you can
figure out how the logic came together
and try to throw yourself a couple other
little logic puzzles like this number 46
how to find the positions of numbers
that are multiples of three from a
series and in here we're actually going
to use a numpy to solve it the first
part series lets you know it's going to
be a panda series and if we come down
here we have
np.org where this is a vocabulary
question series with remember the
percentile three is a remainder so if
the remainder equals zero then we're
going to generate that string where the
object divided by three equals zero has
no remainder so that we know it's a
multiple of three number 47 how to
compute the euclidean distance between
two series and this one's really cool
because we have our panda series uh p
and q and what i like about this one is
they give us two solutions you can go
with and really you should kind of know
both the first one would be yes you know
what the euclidean distance is and that
is we can take the first series minus
the second series squared and then sum
them up and then we do the square root
which is the same as taking the power to
0.5 doing the power to 0.5 is easier
than doing the square root so a lot of
times you'll see that as a switch but
you could have also done the square root
and use the math in there so there's
solution one you should know your
euclidean distance and then solution two
is the numpy solution so we have np dot
lin-alg dot norm that's how we're gonna
compute our euclidean distance
p minus q very elegant and very
straightforward and easy to compute
number 48
how to reverse the rows of data frame so
here we have our data frame we're going
to create a numpy array by 25 reshape it
five minus one and this creates a 25 by
25 data frame and so our solution is to
do the dfi location and this is just
understanding how steps work the steps
you have your colon colon minus one so
we're taking all the rows all the
columns minus one so we're stepping
minus one going the reverse direction
and then we're just going to use across
all the different columns on there let
me say that again the first colon is
going to be your row starting row
stopping row step minus one that's all
this is about is that step minus one
comma and then all the columns 49 if you
split your data into train test splits
is it possible to over fit your model
and the answer is yes it's definitely
possible one common beginner mistake is
retuning a model or training new models
with different parameters after seeing
his performance on the test set my
favorite example of this is you have
your script put together and you keep
hitting the rerun button until you get
the answer you want not taking the
answer it first gave you or running it
over an array recording all the answers
to see how they vary number 50 which
python library is built on top of map
plot library and pandas
to ease data plotting the answer this is
seaborn seaborn is a data visualization
library in python that provides a high
level interface for drawing statistical
information informative graphs we've
covered 50 different questions that
might come up on an interview hopefully
you've taken the time to note the
vocabulary where you're sticking and not
having problems you might have to go
back and relock up v stack versus eight
stack versus concatenate and also review
the axes on those little things like
that also we address some logics how do
you formulate those different polls from
a pandas data frame so that you're
looking at the right data with the minus
one step or an np array how we did
brackets and really fiddled with it i
want to thank you for visiting us today
and joining us for today's python
questions for interviews again my name
is richard kirschner with the simply
learn team for more information visit
www.simplylearn.com or feel free to
leave a comment down below and we will
be monitoring that again thank you for
visiting and happy learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
you